i was like what why the [ __ ] do you have
a blowtorch why don't we just have like
something like a normal life like a
match yeah i don't know he went to go
and point it to start a fire and the
whole blowtorch just went on fire and i
was like uh you might want to put that
out
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i am your host for today
gant and uh with me once again are the
boys and uh we almost died
not clickbait no clickbait that's the
title of this video
that is the title of this video
we almost died camping guys okay okay
now we have to do like why did you say
it so quickly now no one's going to
watch the rest of the episode
now we have to do like the youtuber
thumbnail face of just like oh my god oh
my thumbnail face all right
audio only listening is like what's
happening all right how long did it take
you guys to perfect the youtuber
thumbnail face because god come on we
can't tangent already we literally just
started the topic okay
no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no okay okay we don't talk about that
that's that's the hook that's we'll
start off with the tangent and then
we'll go back to the topic we'll talk
about that but in the meantime but in
the meantime how long does it take you
guys to perfect your youtuber thumbnail
no no okay you're actually in the wrong
question why it's how long did it take
before you stopped becoming ashamed of
yourself doing the youtuber thumbnail
how long has it been since your soul
died this is okay this is a legitimate
question because i still suck at it
because i do anime thought
you just open your mouth i do i do anime
thumbnails right and so i
my entire career has been like anime
thumbnails and so the few videos that i
film in live action i've just been like
a [ __ ] sheep in like headlights your
youtube face is like
my youtube face is just me looking
depressed because i don't know how to
make like any other face you do it very
well i remember i got an angry email
from someone being like why do you make
your thumbnails look like they're for 10
year olds why is your face open and
gasping like an idiot do you have a
penis in your mouth or something like
that they were like because the general
demographic is a ten-year-old's well no
no so i you know i was thinking and then
the explanation is unfortunately you
guys won't click on it
the sad truth is that you know it works
um and it's something that you've come
to see it's like someone asked me when
you take the thumbnail thing do you just
depressingly like sigh afterwards after
you make the pose and i'm like yes yes
yeah absolutely yeah
there's nobody
there's no big like black mirror moment
than when you finish shooting that
thumbnail face shot and then you're just
like
oh okay well now i've got to go in with
my life knowing i just did that so it is
depressing as [ __ ] yeah but uh yeah i
like to me i just
because with thumbnails i feel like you
never perfect it on the first go it's
like i i feel like with thumbnails you
need 15 goals before you know what your
thumbnail style is right sounds like a
rookie really
well you're for you take wonder baby
that's when i'm too lazy and then i get
them too but also there's some
thumbnails where it's like i can't
possibly do a good enough job capturing
this so i'll do some nice little cheesy
clickbait with a character and some
drawings yeah what about you joey how
long how how long would you take on your
thumbnails or do you like do you make a
specific face for that video or is it
just
is it just like a random screenshot from
the video you just filmed do you think
you make the best thumbnails out of
trash taste no who do you think makes
the best dumb though not you think so
yeah i think me who's got the most views
i don't know
well i i think it's uh i think it's
different topics though it definitely
makes the worst that's for sure
i think my thumbnails [ __ ] suck i
like mine a lot i like my i think i like
yours as well
i i get criticized the consistency isn't
there they're like i don't have a
pattern but i also like that it's all
over the place a little bit you get a
different art style every now and then
for me i feel a bit of a double-edged
sword if you develop a pattern because
then your thumbnails start to look same
but that's a good thing because actually
like if you imagine you go and you you
discover a new youtuber right one of the
biggest things that puts me off is like
go i've discovered a youtuber his
content's amazing and then i click on
their channel and it's like all over the
[ __ ] place and i'm just like what
what what is this channel trying to like
what is this channel's content you know
i feel like you like it's kind of like
an instagram page right where it's not
just about one photo it's about when
people click on your entire profile and
they they see like a [ __ ] portrait of
what you're what your profiles are good
example of why my thumbnails suck wait
because they are waiting first of all no
no because now i look like an eu
being i think mine are the best i do
like mine though but i mean i spend a
lot of [ __ ] time doing it and i have
like a bunch of people like consult i'm
like we're like the council getting
around right yeah yeah what do you think
wait why why do you think the reason
your thumbnail wait did you okay wait i
have so many questions i want to ask you
okay did you ask me to be like my
thumbnail suck why would you why would
you upload them if you think they suck
because i can't make battles
why don't you hire someone
uh
the same thing with editing i was like
i'm not i'm not good enough at this
someone else can take my jumbled mess of
words i can work with them they can get
used to my style and then we can go
about it
i don't know then i feel like just like
completely detaches me from my content
i think that's a that's an excuse i
think the thumbnail is like the last
little bit of like me that i can put
into it right and it's like you are the
video though yeah you are you yeah that
is true because like your thumbnail
style is you yeah it's your face yeah
right that that is that is part of i
think it's also because i don't even
know what the [ __ ] i'm doing with my
thumbnails yeah as well like i don't
have like a pattern or anything like
that like i also switch between the
cartoon the my avatar version of me and
my face and it's like like is it a 50 50
clear split or is it i feel like it's
like it's mostly it's mostly your face
now is it the avatar when you because
before it ju it used to be just my
avatar yeah i i think i understand
because it's one it's easier to rely on
avatar you have a lot more room to play
with yeah and the expressions are like
set and it's cleaner yeah when it went
with your face you gotta worry about
lighting you gotta worry about this yeah
yeah exactly i get it is it like when
you cannot get a good one with your face
you bring in the avatar no i just give
up and just use the [ __ ] oh if you are
not happy with it no oh [ __ ] i work with
what i've got basically yeah you need to
get a good uh good artist or somebody
work because i even with my photos now
when the when it's just you'll notice
that there's like text in it yeah all
the text is like hand drawn yeah
everything's all hand done because i
want to get it all to fit nicely when
you [ __ ] around with fonts yeah you can
probably do it yeah but i i want to get
everything perfect so i'll talk with
someone like let's reframe this picture
let's let's move things around it's
gonna just die just right so it looks
nice yeah because like you say you you
think you have the best thumbnails and i
think you definitely do for the content
you made and that's that's why you found
success and like i think i don't know
i'm gonna start my own day here yeah
i feel like my thumbnails are like the
most optimized they can be for anime
style content that's true yes it's a
different yeah
different type of style of content yeah
yeah like if i'm cosplaying like
at the time recording i recently used a
cosplay video yeah that's so easy to
like make a good thumbnail yeah just
literally get the picture of the cosplay
and then just have some whoa that's
that's me yeah yeah that's what i did
because it works exactly right
whereas whereas for me if you like 90 of
the time if you see a video recommended
on your youtube and it has like say a
waifu's face plastered right on the
front with a bunch of memes on the side
or something like that you're gonna know
it's my videos and you're not even gonna
need to see that it's my channel right
because it's a certain style that i've
built up over the years i backtrack
second my own dick and i'll be like we
all make the best thumbnails for what we
do okay
okay
i'm sure somebody could make better
thumbnails for doing the same thing but
the thing though you can never think
like i've got it i've got it nailed
you've got to think like all right how
do i make it better yeah do i improve
this all right i want to make it pop
more yeah yeah
what is the worst thumbnail you think
you've made that you that you can
remember oh there's so many yeah
have you ever like gone back and changed
the thumbnail at all no you've never
i i have like too lazy for that once i'm
done it's gone like that's it like i
don't want to once the video is live i
do not want to think i used to think
about i used to think like that until i
saw that [ __ ] very tasty video that
yeah that said like he goes back and
changes the thumbnail and i tried it and
then like it actually makes a [ __ ]
difference yeah some videos that i
actually changed the thumbnail on title
actually have like a second wind and
they're doing way better than even when
they initially thinking to do it ever
since that veritas video but i just
haven't been [ __ ] adored basically i
was like yeah i'll get to it today yeah
yeah a lot of the older videos i
genuinely don't want people to watch
right right i'm like this is not the
content i make i do not want you
watching hours and hours of sebastian
prank calling and then being like when's
the next one coming out you know like
it's not it's not coming out it's never
coming out right i'm not doing it
anymore let me get out of this this
nightmare situation
you're gonna add anything to that
i was
you know what i don't think i can relate
you know what you know i like i was i
was in my head i was just like can i
relate to this can i relate to this
because i can't relationships who can
my mind was just like i'm sorry like i'm
sorry that happened to you but i'm not
reading that or something like that
who get to this point i've never had to
deal with that because that channel dies
that's true because like i you know i
feel like one of the biggest things
you've done is you've definitely like
changed up your content a lot and you
know i you know you definitely like your
style and your how you promote your
videos and your thumbnails have
definitely changed along the way
right so
you know it's it's it's a nice evolution
but for me like i've been around for so
long that uh there are still videos that
i'm proud of like i've made years ago
not every video of anime in minutes
anime minutes so that's that's
definitely coming back eventually
when's the next one it's uh it's uh it's
like i'm it's just like my hunter hunter
you know it's just it's just on hiatus
i've got back things i've got i've got
trash taste to work on guys come on if
you didn't know the mangakov hunter
hunter has back pains and hasn't wrote
in like over a year i think right he
hasn't released of them over here like
two years ago
jesus yeah
before that it was like six years yeah i
know now i just feel bad whenever
whenever a manga is on hiatus because of
you know [ __ ] berserk by how much how
big of a meme that is and what that
turned into i saw an interview uh with
iraqi
they had one that man works every day of
the week
yeah i bet he's like 60. yeah this man
has never looks 30. he's never going to
stop no
it was insane i was like this man told
his weekly schedule and didn't mention a
break anywhere and he works from i think
10 a.m to 11 p.m with one hour break and
i'm like yeah
bro yeah that's what it takes man to be
the [ __ ] top shonen but like no no
wonder like he has so much musical
reference he doesn't have time to do
anything else because she's listening to
music
and doing stuff yeah pretty much role
yeah yeah like i can't imagine what the
actual life of a manga is like because
you see some youtubers on the grind
right but at least with youtube you can
you can have some variety in there you
can collab and you can do i work for a
lot of content i take breaks yeah
well part of the part of the charm is
that your breaks also happen to be
monetizable right because you that's
that's like your twitch streams right
because that's that's for you that's
your downtime as well as work i guess
technically but with mangakas
you can't do anything but just draw and
work on your [ __ ] work in your series
and i can't imagine being that one
tracked and being that dedicated to just
a single thing in your life for that
long i can't dedicate what i can't
dedicate like a month of my life to one
project let alone [ __ ] five years or
ten years or twenty years entire life
yeah sure i saw a reddit post that was
like um uh it was like uh
uh what's the guy who made uh wrote game
of thrones uh george robin yeah george r
martin he was like he apparently begged
hbo to make ten seasons of game of
thrones instead of the says
you know and i went i you know i opened
this thread
i i half expected what do you think the
comments were going to be when you went
to that thread what would you think of
people would reply get begging for ten
seasons yeah yeah you're apparently
actually he would agree with them they
would agree like yeah go george yeah
maybe yeah no not at all they were like
they were like well if he wasn't such a
lazy piece of [ __ ] and finished his
books maybe we would maybe we would uh
you know we'd have something to work off
of apparently people suck well i don't
know because in some ways apparently he
i can't remember what what exactly but
apparently he was helping writing some
episodes initially and then later on
afterwards he wasn't help helping write
any of the episodes you know isn't that
the reason why like the later seasons
sucked so much was that because he kind
of maybe that was that was that was the
theory right
now i've never seen a single episode
and there was a lot of comments and
there's one or two that i kind of half
half agreed with where i was like okay
it's like all right
if you're not gonna do the job right and
you are the most qualified person for
the job right
and they are doing it with or without
you yeah and you decide no i'm not doing
it and then it becomes [ __ ] yeah can you
then turn around and be like oh it's
[ __ ] they should have just given it more
time
because the argument was like if if
someone's if the job's gonna get done
you're not gonna do it then it's your
fault yeah like it's kind of his fault
people were saying it's because he
should have it's it's not his fault i
mean it's not entirely i understand a
little bit where they were coming from
i'm sure there's like a certain degree
of responsibility but to say that it's
all his fault because he's like the main
guy is a little harsh i think a lot of
people were being very critical of him
in a sense that i thought was a bit
unfair
being critical no well i think it's game
of thrones they've gone to the five
stages of grief with the books yeah yeah
they've like they've gotten to
acceptance now yeah yeah they've
accepted that it's never going to finish
and it's never coming out yeah and i'm
pretty sure
the first time
i'm pretty i'm pretty sure it's like
never coming out like like as an anime
fan i'm like a hardened veteran i'm like
oh this series isn't finished cool give
me the next easter car just give me the
next finish
this is just like the one time where i
opened a reddit thread and i was
genuinely
100
incorrect on what i thought the replies
are going to be yeah right because
reddit is normally a really simple the
first thought that comes to your head
circle jerk yes like oh go for the low
hanging fruit get your karma yeah
everyone have votes yeah you know but it
wasn't that i was quite surprised but i
also find we've read it it also depends
very much on the board you're on because
depending on the board you're on you can
get like very very different replies
because it's all like it's all like a
circle jerk but it's a circle jerk of
people who think alike and not everyone
on the same board thinks of life because
anyone who doesn't just gets shunned
yeah and so some i you know you go on
some reddit threads or some reddit you
know some reddit forums and you see like
this thread and you're like i can't be
the only one who thinks this way and
then you go on the reddit thread and
everyone seemingly in the reddit thread
thinks the exact opposite of you and
you're like am i the crazy one am i the
[ __ ] crazy one and then you see like
the same thing being discussed on
[ __ ] youtube or twitter or something
and it's a completely opposite opinion
yeah you know so i i think it very much
does depend on what board you're on and
what kind what kind of group of people
you're talking to
because i can't imagine everyone would
think that that is jaw george's fault
you know well yeah you know i was
thinking about it and as somebody does
creative stuff obviously not to the same
level and same expectations but you know
you you don't
it sucks because there are probably a
bunch of creators out there who are
legitimately just
being lazy and just like [ __ ]
chilling and not doing anything and yeah
they're like uh whatever whatever and
making that you know and i guess in some
ways that raises the question of
do the fans have a right to demand the
work come out if he doesn't want to make
it anymore and it's halfway through is
that i mean i mean the issue is right
the issue is that
a lot of people
don't really appreciate how much time it
takes to make good [ __ ] yeah right um
i'm sorry joe i'm going to do i'm going
to do this again i'm going to bring up
arcane well once again i know okay yes
i thought you're going to say fate there
foreign i'm going to bring up arcane
once again joey
no because like you know that series
that series took six years to make right
from what i understand it took like five
or six years to make and it definitely
feels like it took five or six years to
make because there's so much like
attention to detail and like so many
different aspects of the show
but like so i can see that this took six
years to make at the same time would i
want to wait six years for a season two
i don't think i would you know i think i
would i'd because uh his thing i don't
know what i would rather would i rather
wait that long for a better product or
would i rather wait
less time for a decent product that i
can at least
like carry like consume it's the [ __ ]
cyberpunk
it's [ __ ] cyberpunk
arcane 10 out of 10. go watch it weekly
reminder to go watch our game um number
two [ __ ] i don't know that's tough
because yeah yeah yeah would you would
you would you think cyberpunk would have
done better if they waited another two
years i think
with a game it's different because a
game is normally one and done like
cyberpunk would be one and done right
it's pretty much it's over right is it
yeah no because they can do updates yeah
yeah but like as in
the the core of the game there's not
going to be a cyberpunk 2
if you've played it there's not going to
be a cyberpunk 2. okay and if there
would i don't know what they would do
but it's going to be like a one thing
whereas like you know
uh arcane ended on a
cliffhanger yes right so when you're
ending on a cliffhanger it's a different
question as to post when you're done
like it's completely wrapped right yeah
cause that's why we can see sees it like
reboots like 10 15 years later cause
it's like okay it's this thing that's
done
and then oh
15 years later you like that thing this
cyberpunk said 2078 right because like
it's done right it's done so it's it's
fine except it actually comes out in
2017. the year is probably
the patch is 10 petrobites
if it's a seasonal thing with multiple
seasons i don't want to wait six years
if it's if it's one thing that i don't i
don't know anything about yeah i can
wait 20 years because i don't give a
[ __ ] about it i don't know what it is
give me the thing that's done and
complete right yeah but now now that we
know there's probably gonna be season
two of arcane yeah i don't wanna wait
six years i don't i don't i don't i
don't even if it ends up being like
mediocre compared to season one i don't
i am fine with it going down from like a
ten out of ten to eight out of ten yeah
i mean let me get it same here because
there's so much potential to this story
where i feel like it would be so
squandered if i'm 50 and i'm still like
waiting for part four of arcane yeah
because like
because like i'm going through the same
dilemma now with also shokutense because
you know that
from what i've heard talking to people
in the industry that took so many
[ __ ] years to make and it definitely
shows that it took that many years to
make that's because of all the business
meetings
and that too
on top of that that was like seventy
percent
the studio did say that um they estimate
2023 for arcane season 2. 2023 that's
that's that's reasonable
yeah i feel like i feel like the reason
why they say six years is because they
probably have those like pre-production
meetings that last like god god knows
how many years yeah like when you
actually start getting all the pieces
moving it's probably a little faster now
that you have more money more manpower
they know that it's a success we know
that it's very successful yeah it'll uh
you know and the merchandising is
endless probably with this and the games
and i think i think we won't be having
any shortage of arc they'll have enough
resources i'm sure i'm pretty sure
riot's going to give them enough enough
resources but i think one thing that
one thing that isn't appreciated is that
you also need talent you know
there's been enough anime projects that
have money thrown at it and it doesn't
help because there's just not enough
talent all like the talented people are
working on different projects right yeah
so it's i don't know it's it's it's a
dilemma i don't know i don't have the
right answers
do you think cyberpunk's 2077 should
have come out when it did probably not
but
how long how long would you have waited
for it because i remember because i
remember when they announced they were
delaying it right they delayed a lot of
people like king take your time brother
take your time the first time did they
first time they they delayed it
everyone's like you know what take your
time you made the witcher 3 i'll allow
it second time that was when people were
getting started to get aggie right now
that's when that's when patience was
tested so if they delayed it a third
time did they delay it a third time i
don't think i think the scope of the
game was just over ambitious
i think it was just too much yeah like
in this current day you can't make what
they were trying to make
to the level that they were advertising
yeah within a reasonable time because
you know the more the more you use you
sink into it there's only so many sales
you can get on a game without dlc and
battle passes and all that and it was
just gonna be a game with maybe dlc
right yeah maybe they'd get some
microtransactions in there but like
realistically it wasn't gonna be
anything that would crush numbers we'd
never seen before right yeah so like i
guess so i know it's it's like how do
you convince the investors to like stick
around and like be happy right because
you've got there's a lot of pressures
right from outside forces oh yeah it's a
business we can't forget and also is it
fair to ask people to spend like 10
years of their life on the same [ __ ]
thing
in some ways i'm like i guess they're
being paid because we like just 10 years
yeah yeah right well my monkeys are
built differently the japanese work
ethic is just saying that we just don't
we just don't have in the west this is
like
those dudes are like rookie numbers got
to pump them up yeah they are well i
mean in the case of the manga because
that's all they have even like iraqi
said right who did jojo right he he said
that the reason why he split it into
parts of generations like he said i
would get bored drawing the same
characters for like 35 years yeah he had
the foresight to see that he would i
don't blame him
could you imagine you've got to draw
[ __ ] mickey mouse like 150 times a
day you blow your brain out
you'd know like the exact size yeah
you'd know the exact good size you had
mickey mouse
can you imagine the [ __ ] jonathan was
still like the main character of jojo to
this day
yeah you didn't even like you you ended
up like not even liking the character
you made after yeah yeah exactly like
you'd lose your mind yeah yeah yeah you
go crazy no that's that i can relate to
because as a youtuber i always like
working on something new you know
working on a new kind of content as i'm
sure you guys do as well right so i
can't imagine yeah also dedicating that
much time to just a single project and i
know there are people who have done that
you know especially in like indie video
games where it's just like a one-man
team working on this one game for
[ __ ] years and years
google uh the russian film that's been
in production for like 50 years
just type that in type that into google
there's this i watched this thing uh
this video from a trustee guide it's
about this video yeah about this russian
animation producer who
hand draws every single like frame oh i
think i know you're talking about he's
like the walt disney of russia right
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's super acclaimed
and famous
like his animations are insane yeah it's
amazing but he's been working on this
one animation for like a ridiculous
amount of years
right it's just like it's never going to
be finished yeah at the rate because
he's like he's like nearly dying he's
very very old and he's like not even
halfway
and it's like 30 40 years in or
something really long
what what kind of movie is he making
it's uh it's it's animated it's an
animated story about i think it's called
the raincoat or something it's a
the overcoat that's it yeah the overcoat
is that what it's called yeah is how
many years have been in production for
four fourteen
for forty years has he released like
previews or is it yeah yeah cause he
just like said guys i'm working on this
video
yes it's coming out the yellow like
delay thing comes out every ten years
it's like guys give give me another 10
years
people reply to it i put work off to
watch this what the [ __ ]
imagine youtubers be like guys i'm
working on something big it's big
ten years later guys i'm still working
on it it's gonna be something it's gonna
be something so they
they've released portions of the film
that you can watch and it is it is very
beautiful yeah but it's also like really
sad because it's like oh this thing this
drawing this set of drawing that has
consumed this man's life yeah and that
has drove this man to insanity yeah and
ruined all of his relationships and
everything because he's also like a dick
to everyone because of course every
director ever is a massive dick of
course um yeah and he's like really
apparently very harsh works insane hours
makes his wife work like crazy as well
right yeah how's it getting paid
uh i think donations
um and kickstarter
indiegogo
all the works you know
god he must have gone through like every
donation platform known to man if we
started 40 years ago so they don't have
any technology in the studio they refuse
to have any technology because of course
they do and they do all by hand but it's
like it's like it's like at what point
when you're making something for so long
are you like all right come on
come on [ __ ] off come on finish it can't
stop now this is a joke yeah sort out
sort out mate
start your life out come on
there's more to life than just as one
project well you know it goes past the
point where it's just like you are just
letting this consume you yeah to a point
where you're not creating any more it's
just it's just taking a whole just an
addiction yeah yeah yeah yeah you're not
you're not this isn't healthy because
you're not going to finish it and
at that point no matter what you release
is never going to be worth the amount of
years
yeah
yeah
i mean there's only a few things that
are worth 40 years of reviews don't get
me wrong it looks amazing but it's also
very sad hearing the story of this guy
and it just takes over his life yeah i
mean he must really love it i'm sure
that's an understatement i don't know i
feel like it's not
the same i think it's an obsession is it
desperation i don't think i don't know
it's probably one of those things where
it's like it's definitely not healthy
yeah
i mean
you know it's not like a passion it
probably is passion but i i think it's
only i think it's obsession which is you
know obsession is different from passion
what's like the longest you guys have
ever worked on a single project i mean
because like you recently just uploaded
your cosplay video you know yeah very
good very good um because i remember
every few weeks or something you'd be
like yeah i'm going to a shoot it's the
cosplay video and i swear that would
like that went on for like a [ __ ]
year or something yeah there was a year
yeah yeah it took a long time yeah i
mean it's all right it's good it's good
fun it wasn't too is that the longest
thing you've worked on yeah no not hours
put in but right as in like time and
number of shoots yeah it was the most
yeah you know and it's fine i mean it
wasn't too hands-on just kind of getting
the edit down was difficult what's like
the most you've ever put into one
project then
oh my gosh
i don't know okay i'll i'll go first
then go first
no no no it's like the most i've ever
put in was [ __ ] must be like 10 years
ago or something now i made this top 20
list called like the top coolest anime
characters of all time or something
along those lines right that sounds
yeah how did this take you years okay so
get this um it was eight parts
it was it was it was an eight part
series right because i would spend part
featuring ten characters no 20
characters oh okay yeah yeah so so every
part would contain like two or three
characters and each part would be at
least like 15 to 20 minutes long right
right and i was working i was working i
was working on this one single project
basically throughout university i
basically wasn't uploading anything but
this one [ __ ] series yeah and i
realized about two videos in after i'd
spent like months just working on two
videos i'm just like
i've made a massive mistake
i did finish it it took me and like it
took me an entire year to finish right
and it took me an entire year to finish
and i remember
when i finished it was basically when i
graduated from university
and i put the script of this top 20 list
next to my dissertation and the top 20
list was twice the length of my
dissertation that i had worked with my
last year
so my dissertation which i spent an
entire year working on was half half
like the length of this [ __ ] youtube
video series that i had worked on in
that same year
so uh that was so good yeah and i don't
know at some point
you you kind of like
it's it's not it's not motivation that's
keeping you going because when you have
a project that big you just want to
finish it just so you can [ __ ] figure
it out yeah
you just want to start yeah but you
can't you started yeah the yowie
audiobook took me like a month of like
uh like it's probably like a month at
least five days a week eight eight to 12
hours
non-stop yeah reading this [ __ ] book
over and over again yeah non-stop read
that book so many times i i hate it i
hate it now i can't look at it it drives
me insane i like it i like it a lot but
i hate it because because like you get
to about 50 60 of the way in and you're
just like this is this is [ __ ] i'm done
i'm not doing this yeah and then you're
like but i gotta finish yeah i just like
there's there's just something about
having
an unfinished project that just
2.0 and i'm just like i did the first
film that to me is like a completed
completed project that's why part of the
big reason i didn't want to didn't want
to continue that was because i didn't
want to put that upon myself again to
start a project that i knew was going to
take [ __ ] years to finish
and that's what like that's that's what
excites me but that's what also scares
me the biggest like the most when it
comes to taking on a big project because
i've got like a lot of different ideas
for a lot of big projects i eventually
want to do but just knowing what it's
like where you're like excited you're
motivated for like the first half and
then that just peters off and you start
hating your project and start hating
yourself and just like i just want to
get this done yeah that's me is just
that that is like such an awful grind
what about you joe what was your longest
i don't know i mean so video stands out
as being like grueling
anything you worked on
music wise or anything i mean music wise
i guess like my first album took like
two years how long were you working on
that album for uh the first album i took
like two years it's like on and off rise
yeah that was on an author because that
was just like a side problem
here and there yeah yeah yeah it's like
whenever i felt like doing it because
it's not really like you know my career
isn't dependent on yeah when did you
feel like it was ready to like be
released you know um because because
because i've had side projects like that
as well there where you do like a
certain percentage and you then you
realize wait a minute this i might
actually get to the end of this yeah i
might actually be able to finish i mean
the first time i was like eight tracks
and i think by like track six i was like
okay
is this enough for an album or should i
add more
not sure and then yeah and then like
after that like it was kind of like a
rush of like inspiration because it's
like you see the you start to see the
final product right and you're like the
goal is right there like i just need i
just need to run to it now yeah um the
last five percent is actually really fun
when it's almost yeah the last five
percent is like hell yeah yeah but um i
don't know in terms of videos not not
too sure i mean i think the reason why a
lot of my videos take so long is because
either
me with whatever i'm working with takes
a long time
yeah back a lot of it is just like
waiting yeah right like so like i did
the
i did that video with ladybeard where we
like run around the uh like a figurine
like factory and like we did that video
that took that video took like eight
months oh god we're counting time just
getting like prep yeah
tell me you're a japanese youtuber
without telling me your japanese
youtuber like that video took me eight
months but seven of those months was
just waiting for them to give me the
okay yeah and forgive me a good date to
start and then the actual shoot took
like a day and a half so it's like yeah
you know i i feel like in terms of like
just sheer working on a video uh time
like maybe
i don't know a month it's like max i
can't tell you which video it is but i
have like a couple of videos like that i
feel that with trash taste specials
though as well oh yeah
is just like so [ __ ] long that
sometimes you forget that they're coming
out yeah you're like what did was this a
good special i can't remember like i
remember
seeing the first draft of the drifting
special on the cycling special i
remember my first thought was god i
can't believe i had wasted all this time
to like record this [ __ ]
like by the time this episode comes out
the cooking special is probably out
right yeah yeah i mean i guess we can
talk about that because like that oh my
god that first draft took like how long
that's just because i think you know it
was one of those situations where trash
taste takes priority yeah and because
we're not you know because we know
people are willing to wait we do it does
take a while because it's not
prioritized at all like we don't say and
i guess we we do want it to be like the
best [ __ ] call yeah yeah we don't
mind making weight because you know
so much work goes into the shoot
it's the one thing i don't want to
compromise on in terms of like quality
yeah um can we talk about the kendo
special
i guess sure okay so so yeah so
we released the picture of us filming a
kendo special and uh god
and like that was like months and months
and months ago and a lot of viewers may
have just like forgotten about it but i
know i see some reddit posts every now
and again bringing that special up like
when's the kendo special coming when is
it coming uh we actually scrapped the
special because we
we filmed for an entire day um we got
all the source footage and then mudan
edited a first draft and we thought it
was [ __ ] it was [ __ ] and
we thought like there's only like uh
there's only so much we can save through
editing and voiceover because the source
footage unfortunately just wasn't there
so we had to make the decision to just
do we try and maybe frame this maybe
release this as a mini special or maybe
like something
something different maybe it goes in the
after dark channel but we eventually
came to the decision that uh we spent an
entire day he's filming we hired like
three cameramen four maybe four and
ashley as a sound guy we hired the kendo
people um and we uh scrapped it we just
we just like i think like in general it
there was like self room for salvation
but i don't think it would have i think
we can all agree it wouldn't have been
up to the standard of that where we see
trash taste
yeah it could have been like a decent
just like you know vlog style video or
anything like that yeah but like yeah as
a as a special and especially after the
cycling special like yeah
you know we didn't we wanted to make
something that was at that level of
quality or above yeah kendo special no
matter how much we could do no matter
how much mudan could do yeah just would
not get to that stand itself yeah
exactly yeah and uh i mean that doesn't
mean we're not going to do a kendall
special part of the reason we
decided to scrap it was because we saw
potential to
make it right and make it make it make
it learn a lot on that show we did learn
a lot i mean you you don't learn without
failing right exactly and you know it
[ __ ] it [ __ ] hurt because i
remember i remember we were discussing
what to do with this special for so
[ __ ] long i was like do we release it
do we try and do something without do
something with it and it was just on the
back burner for like months and months
and then it was a hard decision but i
feel like it's moments like this where
you really really [ __ ] learn
something and part of the reason i think
the cooking special is going to be good
was because we took so many of the
lessons that we learned from this failed
special
which we may reboot to a proper special
that meets our standard but we we took
so much from this one experience which
was a very expensive you know mistake
you know it was it wasn't expensive
experience but uh that's that's kind of
like that's kind of like the quality the
bar of quality we want to set yeah at
least for our specials a [ __ ] a
[ __ ] podcast we can just argue about
bone on chicken or [ __ ] whatever
shitty food take we get for like a
millionth time and that's fine you know
yeah but the special is like something
we really want to make sure we like
[ __ ] hit the nail yeah but uh yeah i
mean hopefully hopefully i mean the
cooking special will be out by the time
this episode comes out so uh it's the
previous it's the episode before this
one
oh it's the episode before this one
yeah
i'm sorry 81 special cooking special
yeah
yeah by the time you guys have seen this
you can see the cooking special from
last year but uh we don't know as of us
recording right now
uh so yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed
you got robbed robbed
[ __ ] no you didn't
you were never close to winning connor
yes
was an impartial judge she played her
role perfectly
she was the chaotic evil that we needed
in that video
impartial judge bro
dude dude it's caused my sweat just you
know it tasted better obviously
obviously that was the reason yeah this
you're missing this if you haven't
watched it go wash the trash taste go
watch the trash chase cookie special we
did put a lot of work into it yeah but
uh i think like the aim for 2022 for us
is to like maybe get
a couple more specials out that'd be
nice i mean
without without compensating quality
right yeah yeah i mean i mean we've got
a few ideas which i think are going to
be really really good um they're going
to be big um as well so don't worry
about yeah it's it's all bad we did we
could have done more yeah we could have
no because we could have we could have
we could have but it would have been
like really difficult in the year that
we had yeah especially with the
restrictions it was it was very
difficult but part of part of part of
the reason was every time we come up
with a special idea we just like go to
like mailing or geeks plus and be like
oh can we can we can we get approval for
this place and they'd be like nope
everything's on the lockdown right now
pretty much that would just delay things
for another few months and then the next
few months and then that just like that
was just the first
three quarters of the year basically and
then scrapping the ones really set us
back on the schedule yeah it's a bit
unfortunate really so could we you could
have had two specials this year but we
scrapped one special ideally we want
what three yeah is that the soft thing
that we you set three or two i'd like at
least two i think three i don't i don't
want to like push too fast as as someone
who just cut back to uh two uploads a
month that's because three was too much
let's promise
i must say two a year let's promise two
at least but let's check for three let's
try three we'll try for three because
some of the ideas we have are going to
take months of [ __ ] planning
yeah i haven't already two at least
three maybe i like i would like to i'm
the optimistic side of me says three
years yeah but the realistic side of me
says two of you yeah
we we got our streams we got our streams
we're focusing on as well
you know and all three of us are like
we'll get through poorly let's do five
let's do no [ __ ] let's do one a month
one
month
you know i remember when i saw we are
hiring about 20 content producer roles
right i remember when i started anime in
minutes and i promised one a month and
uh look look how look how that turned
out well that's just clown that's clown
buffoon right there
you can't bro how are you gonna schedule
voice acting sessions bro
i thought i had min maxed it and then i
realized that i couldn't get it to the
it actually wasn't the uh voice acting
side it was just the scripting side
where i couldn't get it to
the
quality that i wanted for every series i
think it's also just gonna be hard to do
three a year not only because of you
know like the after dark stuff we're
doing as well but also just the fact
that i think like on all of our main
channels we're just gonna like 2022 is
just like another stepping quality up
yeah and just time taken so it's like
yeah we need all the help we can
basically
help us please help help
i would like to like just for myself i
would like to get at least two out yeah
i think i think that's a good i mean i
mean we we could have easily done it
last year yeah and we did film two last
years we did do last two so if if one
wasn't if one wasn't a learning
experience we would we would have had
two so that i think that we didn't [ __ ]
up you'd have to yeah
yeah unfortunate circumstances made us
[ __ ] up yeah you know it's whatever but
speaking of something that is uh not
going to be a special just yet
we almost died
wow
call back
whoa connor needs to pee what what what
is this
keep this in mood on this is rare
evidence of connor asking for a toilet
break before me or
before me or joey have even asked i've
never asked to pee before you know i
i'll take this i'll take this rare
opportunity to also people yeah i might
as well
this episode is sponsored by expressvpn
watching netflix without using
expressvpn is like paying for a gym
membership but only using the treadmill
i can relate
to elaborate on that comment i just made
expressvpn allows you to change your
location which means that you get access
to netflix's full library of content
they have over 100 different server
locations so you can gain access to
thousands of new shows this works with
many other streaming services too like
bbc iplayer youtube and more so on
netflix i can't watch saving private
ryan one of my favorite war movies it's
not available in japan so what i do is i
flick on expressvpn move it over to a
new country and bam it's ready and
available to watch so simple plus it's
compatible with all your devices phones
laptops media consoles smart tvs and
more expressvpn also encrypts all your
data it has the added benefits of
encrypting your data so you can browse
the web safely and securely so don't be
stupid be smart stop paying full price
for streaming services and only getting
access to a fraction of their content
get your money's worth at expressvpn.com
trash taste and don't forget to use our
link expressvpn.com
trash taste to get an extra three months
of expressvpn for free back to the
episode and we are back from our piss
break why did you just say that because
because it's kept in this time so they
they knew that we were having a picture
there was like at least an ad in between
that or something you know
just to break it otherwise would be very
awkward no
we're either coming back from an ad
break or a piss bridge or a pace break
or both who knows but yeah uh as god
said we almost
died really and but not really it's it's
no i mean it's it's a youtuber we almost
died like yeah under certain
circumstances i'm sure we could have
died but it felt like i was dying yeah
that's for sure but uh yeah so you guys
probably saw on our social medias uh
that if you don't follow us on twitter
yes please follow us all on twitter and
trash days as well but uh we posted a
couple of photos of us going camping and
uh so many people thought they were like
yeah
it's not a bad idea but we do you know
we do like to hang out as mates as well
there is thought that sometimes we just
hang out with our cameras
holy [ __ ] are we allowed to do that is
that legal oh no we didn't take pictures
we did
like come on that's not part of my
contract not cameras in there but we did
we didn't film it i was going to vlog it
for the second channel but i was having
too much fun where i was like [ __ ] it
yeah maybe not vlog what i was just
getting smashed yeah yeah exactly
yeah so basically uh nabi who uh works
behind the camera as well as a bunch of
his friends and three of us we went
camping to mount fuji and it was [ __ ]
awesome
it was awesome until it was awesome
until we almost died until we had to
sleep and uh it is uh the first time
i've been camping in these kind of
weather situations same um so it was the
first time so camping in england right
the most you gotta [ __ ] worry about
is some mild rain a lot of times it's
like a mild annoyance i've camped in the
winter before i think in the uk yeah i'm
pretty sure but it wasn't that cold yeah
right like how how cold does it get in
the uk in the winter it depends where
you are in the uk because it's like a
lot of places snow right in the uk yeah
yeah snow's fine though
that's all right sounds all right yeah
snow isn't that cold i mean it was
it wasn't even snowing where we were
[ __ ] hot everything was frozen yeah
yeah frozen is like worse than cold yeah
yeah that's like when the grass is
frozen it's like way colder because then
when the snow compacts it doesn't feel
as cold yeah why well we basically went
to this place called fumotopara which uh
if you've watched your camp is is the
place where is it
actual europe that's actually where they
went it's actually yeah it's like the
actual location
which is why which is why there's so
many euro camp references they [ __ ]
lie to me they [ __ ] lie to me they
made it look comfy they made it look
[ __ ] what's comfy about negative five
degrees weather trying to sleep in a
[ __ ] tent there was nothing comfy
about that let me give you the uh the
lowdown yeah please please please please
do all right first of all this it began
in a group chat right yeah camping trip
we're like we're gonna do a camping trip
group chat i'm checking out immediately
i'm that one friend that doesn't read
the group chat i don't know i don't look
at it whatever if you want something
from me message me i don't open group
chats because the moment i see 20
messages i'm like all right peace
i'm not i'm not reading twitter give me
your cliff notes yeah i'm like someone
just tell me yeah and then i'm sorry for
your loss but i'm not reading that
i don't know about you boys it's my my
pov yeah it's like a few days before and
i'm like oh yeah [ __ ] i don't have
anything
i realized i didn't have anything i was
like oh yeah i have camping stuff
thinking back to like the uk i'm like
yeah i [ __ ] i don't have camping stuff i
didn't i didn't right yeah i thought i
had a sleeping bag i did not have a
sleeping bag okay yeah and i didn't
bring a chair i forgot about that so i
had to buy a chair last minute so i
wanted amazon panickingly like the two
days before because uh they told me to
buy stuff because i was like oh [ __ ] i
didn't buy storage so i started looking
and um
there was only one sleeping bag that was
available to be delivered in time before
i left i could have gone to a store i
don't want to go to a store yeah so i
was like i'll get one of amazon i'm lazy
i bought a chair too and it arrived the
chair was very heavy very big i was like
[ __ ] two fair was worth that right yeah
the chair the chair came in i i think i
had the best chair in the end actually
it was this chair
because joey's one had water damage from
like the amount of times he'd like put
it outside yeah this chair is quite
heavy very big i'd say it's not that big
actually that's bigger but it was a
chair where the back was connected to
the legs so when you leaned on the back
the legs popped up and i don't know man
it was so sad it was like a reclining
chair but camping yeah yeah anyway so i
got all the stuff right and i'm like all
right i've been camping a ton before
it's whatever i don't need to buy too
much it's one night one night camping is
like bro i could just do that with like
my clothes i'll just sleep on the grass
it's not a big deal right like i'll be
fine yeah
because i've done that before i've we've
like slept outside with just sleeping
bags we have done that oh yeah yeah
exactly um no 10. yeah yeah yeah you've
done that yeah i've done i've done it to
you it's not a big deal i thought it
would be fine if the weather's good
especially
and then uh
nabi was like oh did you get like a
thermal wear i'm like
get them away
i'll wear a hoodie bro it's fine mind
you we went like first week in december
so most places in japan it hasn't quite
gotten to like winter weather it
definitely isn't that cold in tokyo okay
here's the thing right and i was he said
that to me and i was like oh look how
cold it's gonna be it predicted like one
degree yeah and i was like one degree is
fine if i'm sleeping in my clothes in a
sleeping bag
one degree is fine if i'm wearing
because i had like a hoodie and a big
coat i had a long sleeve shirt yeah i'll
be fine i'll be fine i was not fine okay
we're talking about celsius by the way
yes i'll show you
celsius for american that's four
lollipops actually uh because you want
to convert that um
sorry
it's like 36 fahrenheit it's very full
yeah so so i you know that's what we
thought was going to be so yeah we had a
great time right we got in the car yeah
yeah played some beats we we had a nice
car journey two-hour car journey to fuji
you know it's pretty chilly from tokyo
and got the most insane views of
mountains oh yeah
my god i mean you saw the pictures the
[ __ ] views the reason we went in
winter was because there's no mist no
cloud at all right it's just a clear
picture of mount fuji and
the every picture i took of mount fuji
actually looks photoshopped oh yeah yeah
it's unfucking we put that green screen
to work
it was amazing like there was no cloud
in sight right yeah it was you know
insane
there i was getting kind of toasty i was
getting a little bit too hot i had to
take my hoodie off the sun wasn't the
sun was out i was going to be yeah
i was one layering i was like bro this
is going to be easy yeah and then you
know
if all else failed i would have beer so
if i got super cold at least i would be
moderately drunk and i could sleep yeah
yeah right so i thought that was also my
strategy
it might never matter this is a
foolproof plan yeah nothing could go
wrong and like we we've been camping
before zombie and joe and we weren't
going to make the same mistake uh we
bought way too many beers this time we
bought like two crates beers two two
more crates of beers than we actually
needed in the end
um yeah because i thought everyone's
gonna pull their weight yeah i mean yeah
i mean everyone had the same around the
same amount yeah i'm saying something
oh really one beer what the [ __ ] from
like 72 beers that we bought that is not
pulling your weight because i i think we
all had like maybe seven i was very
drunk yeah it's like seven or eight
beers i'm i'm gonna say that uh some
people i heard weren't able to sleep
during like during the trip yeah uh
because it was so cold and i'm just
saying i did sleep with lit and uh i had
some beers so what can you say what can
you say right what can you say life hack
we go to the nearest supermarket to this
uh place we raid their entire beer stock
their bread stock their sausages [ __ ]
the sausages are so good yeah there's
just something about sausages on a
charcoal grill that just hits me okay
but sausage is the best i don't know why
okay i i'm gonna say uh when we were
buying sausages everyone's just like oh
just just buy the
original buy more buy more no you're
just saying just buy the original flavor
you just buy the original flavor and i
pick up the chili cheese flavor and
everyone looks at me such disgust
everyone looks at me with like such
disgust of like gone what are you doing
get your trash taste out of here and
then when we started eating it it it it
was like the sausage that went the
quickest you know everyone has some
everyone loves them
[ __ ] you joey that's not what you were
saying earlier no no because i got i was
curious because everyone around me was
like yeah these julie jesus ones are
really good i'm like i bet i had it and
i was like okay it's pretty alright
things you can use that excuse for like
you know drunk trying sausages you think
that you think that holds up in the
court of law with drunk driving no it
doesn't joey it doesn't it does it does
can't believe i would get betrayed by
this because he said it doesn't mean it
was a good decision
i didn't quite kill another person
eating this sausage you killed him you
killed my spirit joker
when i killed my taste buds you killed
you killed my spirit that's all that
matters man
i'll send this i'll say this so we
raised
the supermarket we take everything we
get every condiment known to me i was
glad you know sometimes people you know
when they buy all the meat and stuff
they forget to buy the continents but
arguably we bought too many condoms
this bougie [ __ ] bought dijon i
didn't i didn't that wasn't me
you bought
when we were on a bbq i'm like bro just
get the [ __ ] squiddy
and it was like the one in the jar yeah
the one with the jaw like a knife
well there was no knife so i was like
what do you expect just [ __ ] like
we'll get like get in the [ __ ] dijon
on my hot dog by the way there was no
hot dog buns in because sometimes they
don't have hot dog buns in the
supermarkets in japan so we did the the
joey way of doing it which is folding a
piece of australian weight the
australian way
getting one one slice of bread and
rolling it folding it around that's this
it was kind of sad
that's the only way to do it it was okay
it's fine it tasted fine but it just
looked sad it looks sad it it literally
does the same thing i didn't do the same
job
actually if anything you could taste the
same
i would argue it's better because you
eat less bread therefore you have more
space for sausages i agree i i never i
never finished the entire sausage um
like the hot dog the hot dog buns are so
thick yeah the entire the entire hot dog
you know because there's always there's
always like more bread needed than the
sausage in it
are you i'm
i can't believe these takes actually i'm
not even i'm not even you know what i'm
both buns are overrated i'm
what are you talking about i refuse to
start to go down to the level of clowns
i'm not arguing this okay i'm gonna let
that take speak for itself i'm just
gonna say i don't agree respectfully i
disagree
i think the bread is the perfect amount
anyway
i can't believe you just said that
i can't believe this i'm gonna say no no
okay okay so we take we buy the whole
foods of the supermarket it's too thick
it's not it's literally
it is like the second it's it's pretty
thick right it's like twice the
thickness people who love hot dogs are
dying right now dying in the inside
that's all okay so we spend 400 on on
this food for like nine seven nine eight
eight of us
so we bought it all and we finally
started setting up our camp yeah and
getting the fire going which is the most
we got two fire pits going yeah and then
uh we we bought like two little baby
stacks of like plywood or whatever it
was like it wasn't plywood but it may
well been like two by fours yeah and
luckily the stall there sold a [ __ ] ton
of firewood so we bought a [ __ ] ton of
fireworks oh yeah in japan you have to
buy your firewood you can't just like go
into the bush no no no no you got to buy
your phone it's too far in most places
in uh most campsites like official ones
you can't do that yeah oh really in
europe as well you can't stop chopping
down trees unless the site says you can
but most people don't do like most
people don't know how to chop down the
tree though
but like in australia we don't like go
around you know [ __ ] deforesting or
anything but like you know if you go out
into the bushes
and stuff like that you bring it back
like that's problem is though that
branches burn super fast right that's
where you're gonna get like the thing
these are like like you know almost
rotting wood yeah so they sold these uh
really thick pieces of oak that were
great it was wonderful we started
setting up a fire and we started
barbecuing it's great yeah it's
fantastic great so happy you're having a
fantastic time it was like a comfortable
temperature as well it was like probably
like you know maybe five degrees
i think i would say it was even like
warmer than that i was like really like
six maybe six seven degrees what a great
time stop cracking over the beans yeah
started enjoying the food it was
brilliant yeah joey laughed at how i had
a hot dog one time or something i
remember you were like what are you like
laughing your ass off how i had this hot
dog one time oh yeah yeah yeah i like
we were like five or six beers in and
conor was obviously like you know
getting a little bit tipsy and he took i
don't know it just caught my eye like i
just i just looked over and connor had
this hot dog bite and it looked like the
hot dog was trying to escape out of his
mouth because i shoved half the hotdog
in his mouth he just went all i heard
was this like you know like the [ __ ]
video of the the pufferfish eating the
carrot and then it does like oh sound
like i heard that cut out of conor's
mouth as he was shoving this hot dog
he's like oh
i was like oh my god he's like pissing
himself because i was laughing because i
was like bending over because because
there's a lot of sauce on it because i
put i did the rookie area of putting
away too much condiments and i knew the
condiments was going to come out right
yeah yeah and what had happened was that
i think i think i had taken a bite that
was so big that i either committed to
putting it all in my mouth in one go
or if i bit it and stop
the condiments would just go all over me
so i bet i bent forward and just shoved
it all in and one and then all the
condiments like fell down hey yo this
boy's [ __ ] down a hot dog
it was just so good man
i don't know what it is for some reason
with hot dogs when it comes to barbecues
like i can eat like two burgers and i'm
like oh [ __ ] yeah hot dogs i'm like
another one another one please i'm like
six and i'm like let's go another hot
dog not a hot dog to be fair those
sausages will really i actually think i
actually prefer hot dogs over burgers
in a barbecue because like in a barbecue
you have one burger and that's that's
enough for me that's enough that's like
to if if we're gonna go with like how
many like courses are structured to me
like the burger is the main course right
but i can eat so much of like the hot
dog around the burger you know you start
off with hot dogs and you have the
burger and then for some reason you can
eat like three more hot dogs sometimes
it's like it's like my stomach is an
infinite hole when it comes to hot dogs
when it comes to hot and we also had
like the skewers as well which we just
got demolished in like five minutes as
well because they were so good and like
yeah what is it about burgers that is
just like on a different scale of like
filling compared to like everything else
we bought i don't know i don't get it i
think it's just because it takes that
much more effort to cook i guess right
because you have to like you have to
like build the burger as well and it's a
lot bigger you know it's it's it's not
just something it's not just something
you can you know casually pick up off
the grill and just start eating you
gotta
you gotta make sure it's like a nice
burger that you like you gotta make sure
the cheese is perfectly toasted the way
you want it to be toasted um we tried to
like butter our bread but like the
butter was so [ __ ] cold that i think
i think it was edo or something who uh
tried to uh put butter put blocks of
butter on the burger bun so it was like
squares of butter on this burger bun
because it was like too cold to be
spread and then he just like chucked it
on the fire just chucked it on the fire
and all the chunks just fell down
and he was adamant that he could
perfectly butter this buttered
i was watching the entire time i was
like what what did you want to do
i was like what are you expecting he's
just buttering the fire
in my mind when you're at a and you're
barbecuing stuff i'm like i expect the
quality of this burger to not be as on
par as a restaurant yeah i don't need my
my barbecued uh burger buttered yeah i'm
like you can just toast
but it wasn't even like the worst idea
that happened during the this was a good
idea i know you're gonna say this
because because like you know when
you're a few drinks then you do
something that you think is a good idea
and it's like it works in your mind a
genius so we had we also had eggs right
but we had nowhere to cook the eggs so
kind of like a grill right well yeah we
didn't have any pans or anything no no
pans we just had like a grill a mesh
grill right uh so kind of comes up with
the idea of trying to to cook this egg
on a burger bun
and
you know
i really wanted an egg on my burger all
right so what he does is he places the
patty on the grill and then it was the
bun oh sorry the pond so he places the
bun on the grill and then he cracks an
egg on top of it naturally all the white
of the egg just [ __ ] spills over
there yeah
i knew that all has left is a [ __ ]
yolk and this yolk is like it's like ice
hockey it was just like slippering
around on this thing and he's just like
trying to [ __ ]
control it yeah and then in the end it
uh it spilled over it went in the fire
and it was a very sad moment yeah and i
was saying there's no way you could cook
an egg on a burger bun on a grill that's
just like this there's so many things
that can go wrong and it did go here's
what my thinking was is obviously i was
a few years in but i was i thought that
the flames of the fire were so big
because it was like enveloping the bun
yeah i was like it'll reach the egg
it'll cook the egg yeah it'll do it it's
hot enough it'll do it the entire time
as well he was like galaxy brain galaxy
brain watch this game of moment game of
moment i'm just like you are wasting a
perfectly good egg no i had an eggy bun
and it gave the a good egg flavor to
mine there was like one fifth of the
yolk left over
hey it was good it just means you just
made eggy bread yeah i liked it i liked
it it was good it was good
it's like the world's shittiest french
toast it was amazing i had a great
burger
because like you are you are so
dedicated to cooking this egg and it was
like watching someone try to [ __ ]
solve that zelda puzzle in breath of the
wild
we know we know how [ __ ] shitty it is
like controlling controlling that puzzle
with like your wiimote or whatever
you're going to sit in your comfort of
knowing what works i i am the daring
type i tried something new i just i
wanted to see if i could get an egg to
cook on a burger i knew it wasn't going
to go well because the whole ordeal
started with connor going watch this
and you know anything that starts with a
confidence watch this five beers is not
going to go well imagine if it worked
though i'd have been like a [ __ ] i
would have applauded i would have been a
god amongst men yes i made that work
that would have been amazing yeah but
you know you know
too close to the sun you know i tried
something that i shouldn't have
what can i say i you know
it was it was nice and then you gave up
and just like flipped the burger and
then the rest the egg just went into the
fire i wanted i was like all right if i
can't have the egg cooked perfectly on
the bun i'll at least have this french
toast yeah yeah yeah to add too exactly
yeah
it added uh out of the flavor profile
that i was quite happy with so suffice
to say that
the dinner went well and then you know
under the stars there's amazing
starlight and with the you was amazing
we were in the background we're having a
good time there was a problem though we
were running out of wood yes and the
story closed i i was i was going to say
so uh we ate like kings and we drank
like kings we uh we learned from the
last camping trip we over stocked on
pretty much every [ __ ] resource we
could think of our food we did perfectly
um no because we we had we had a bunch
of food we still had a bunch of food
yeah i thought we ate it all yeah well i
mean i ate it while you were if somebody
told me i would have ate it all i would
have done okay no we no it's because
it's because uh we ran our call yeah and
we ran out of firewood um in in camping
outside on a winter's night we went we
ran out of the one resource that uh is
essential for basically human survival
which is heat it kind of sucked because
it was like oh i'm pretty sure we could
still keep going yeah but i got about 11
pm and we were we could see them no no i
i i i remember it got to about 9 00 p.m
right i remember because it got to about
9 p.m and we still wanted to cook some
more food uh but
the the wood just wasn't bringing enough
heat to actually like cook stuff because
it was just charring it and then like
going out right because we needed coal
for it so we decided to stop cooking and
just keep on drinking
as you do you know just as you keep
going with the liquid dinner yeah um but
i remember it hit about 9 00 p.m and it
started getting a bit nippy like it
started going from like a comfortable
temperature to okay now i gotta put on
this winter jacket because i'm actually
starting to feel this cold it went down
to maybe around like two three degrees
maybe so yeah yeah yeah and then i
remember looking at the firewood and uh
we had someone we had somehow gone
through about 70
of the firewood that we had bought
previously and i remember thinking
[ __ ] how much how much longer is this
going to last us right and i remember it
was at that point that i think we
subconsciously started to like ration it
because like it got colder but i
remember the fires also started to get
colder as well because we weren't
putting in the we weren't putting in the
wood like all willy-nilly anymore we
were like i noticed that like people
were slowly approaching the fire pit
like yeah yeah
i was further away initially because i
was like i don't need that much i'm fine
yeah but then like got to the point
where i was like oh i need the fire or
i'm actually going to like just die yeah
like our knees were basically in the
fire yeah made me realize how shitty
fires are you know they must have had to
like literally like sleep next to it
because i'm like this [ __ ] is awful yeah
the range of this fire is terrible i
mean uh air is a terrible insulator
but i was like this is terrible i have
to have basically have my hands in this
thing
nature nerf the aoe of fire
can they fix that patch can they have
the can i have the range increase to
fire it was not yeah i don't know i
don't know what [ __ ] newton was
thinking yeah well what's what's what's
up with that what's up he's trying to
win nerf in the air it's too powerful no
because i remember the fire was like hot
enough being close to it but then my ass
was like freezing [ __ ] cold oh yeah
so every so often like i just have to
like put my ass on top of the fire and
then like joey was just [ __ ] farting
non-stop throughout the entire camping
trip and like every time he put his ass
up across the fire i'm like joey please
don't fart right now like i like ho i
had held my breath right because because
like i knew like joey farted i swear to
god it would have used up the rest of
the firewood that was like
the one just started
okay first of all when you when you
stand up for a moment
the chair that you've been warming up
for like 30 minutes yeah it instantly
becomes cold again it's instantly
freezing it sucks which meant like you
didn't want to move but you had to pee
you had to also like just put stuff on
the fire yeah it was awful and also the
one thing that happened where i was like
we're gonna die is that they try to
light i think the fire starters with a
gas
fire right yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
oh yeah i remember that so they tried to
light one of their guys turned on the
gas for this uh this it was basically
like a uh what would you even call it
blow torches
but we had a blow torch and he lit he
lit it right he went to go and point it
to start a fire and the whole blowtorch
just went on fire and i was like uh
you might want to put that out and it's
the torch is catching on fire the gas
canister is right next to it i'm like oh
oh oh oh fire plus can uh pressure oh
yeah
and i i was like i'm getting away what
the [ __ ] put it out put it out
yeah the thing is we were like six or
seven because everybody else is
just watching this guy holding this gas
canister on fire
i'm running away and i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you guys doing run yeah because
like we said i remember my exact pov was
i see it happen like i see him pointing
it towards the fire he presses the
button and then the gas just leaks on
like throughout the entire can so the
entire count is just covered connor goes
like fight or flight mode he's just like
when that one quiet kid like reached for
his back you know he's [ __ ] half he's
[ __ ] quite a mile down right i'm not
getting near and like and like me being
like six cans of beers in i'm just like
oh fire
and then it was only after connor's like
guys what the [ __ ] you doing we almost
just died and i'm just like but the fire
it's so pretty yeah
he was like holding this yeah he's so
cool these guys didn't even say anything
they literally sat there like stoners
just watching this yeah i literally like
saw him holding this can of fire and i
was just like
the guy like i don't know who was
holding it
was holding and he was like
oh what should i do
and then i was giving instructions i was
like all right now turn it off
i remember you running to a distance and
you're like guys what the [ __ ] you doing
what are you doing and i'm just like
oh yeah should probably uh care for my
life yeah i remember thinking that i'm
just like either run or help
that helps you off should we all right
she'll be all right yeah so uh yeah um
don't uh don't do what we did uh we what
did connor did the correct thing and the
pack could have helped but also i would
have run around the fire and i don't
know how dangerous this is my guess my
best friend would have been how about we
just leave it on the floor and then all
run yeah
so yeah so that happened and i can't
remember if anything else uh happened
during the campsites i'm pretty sure
these gas canisters have fail safe so
that even if they somehow light on fire
like yeah yeah yeah
i don't know
but also i know that you can't heat up a
metal gas canister for very long before
it goes boom yeah that's true that's
true and i'm sure the campsite would
have loved that well we were all right
yeah we're all right we survived
we didn't end up on our slash watch
people die so don't worry they're all
good all it took was a few shakes and a
bit of a blowing yeah exactly yeah
exactly it wasn't it wasn't a big fire
but it was just like fire plus gas
canister not good yeah that's ended very
badly under any are there any under any
other circumstance i would have been in
the same panic mode but uh i kind of
don't know why i i don't know
i was drunk okay very drunk shockingly
calm yeah i was like
just put it out just put it out
i remember the thought going through my
mind of i should get up and run but the
seat's so comfy right now
and it's really cold outside it was it
was like your mom asking you to get out
of bed when it's like about seven a.m it
is how people do this people die
it is how people die it's i was very
stupid but
at the time it just felt like the right
thing to do in my mind which it wasn't
it wasn't i was very we could have died
multiple times this is like a double
entendre at this time yeah yeah exactly
we almost died yeah we actually did yeah
yeah but uh yeah so then that happened
and then it got to around like what 11
p.m when we were
11 pm i could i could have still kept
going yeah me too i wanted to keep yeah
but it got to the point where my entire
life i've been conditioned to think that
no matter how cold it gets i can just
drink more beer and solve the problem um
this was the one time when i was outside
with a thick jacket on and drinking more
beer didn't solve the problem yeah
because i just kept getting colder and
i'm just like what's going on i'm so i
started trying to drink more beer and it
just i just kept getting colder i'm just
like what
is well the thing with alcohol is that
you don't actually get warmer yeah yeah
i just think sure i know you just think
you're getting warmer so that just
that's just a testament to how cold it
was actually getting rather than how
cold my mind was thinking it was getting
because at a point i just like wanted to
stop drinking the beer because i would
pick it up and it would just literally
be freezing yeah it was it was not even
nice to drink because of how cold it was
yeah because outside was so cold would
have been great in the summer oh in the
summer yeah oh no it would have been
amazing but you know when it's like you
know zero degrees outside and you're
drinking zero degree beer it was one of
the few times where you drink a beer and
it gets colder the longer you drink it
right
like the beers would like because they
were in a crate the beers would start
off at a reasonable amount of coldness
and then they would get like a
reasonable coldness to like ice cooled
like almost frozen yeah also the thing
about ice cold beers that's nice is that
you're not normally drinking it in ice
cold conditions yeah exactly so it warms
up but it's a nice temperature and it's
and it's nice in your body so yeah it's
refreshing but when it's just ice cold
in ice cold conditions you're like it's
totally this feels like a bad idea it
feels like a bad combination yeah
perhaps lukewarm beer would have been
though or hot beer that's why they drink
hot wine in the christmas festival yeah
so we did everything we could to
elongate this fire but nothing was
working okay there was only there was
only so much we could ration out this
firewood i think i think the last log
lasted like us like for a full hour
there's there's only so many like tiny
little twigs you find on the on the
paddock right there where it's like yes
this will do yeah yeah i remember there
was a tree next to where i pissed and i
like i like picked up the leaves right
and i'm just like okay these dead leaves
these these will work and they gave us
like like a microsecond of heat and that
that felt like that felt like to me at
the time like a full 10 minutes right
yeah we start we start like using the
[ __ ] uh
we started using like the beer packaging
so it was like we had like we had like
all the cardboard packaging and we were
like we went from using the beer
cardboard to like rationing it as like
as like a as like a big burst of heat
because that would give us like a nice
big bust that he like a good five
seconds we'd all crowd around and we
were like all right boys when do we do
the next one when do we use the next one
and we eventually just can't wait any
longer
we eventually just didn't even drink the
beers but we just still unwrapped
unwrapped the beers with all the
packaging so we could use it as fuel but
uh we should have recycled but instead
we needed heat yeah yeah but uh
eventually eventually
uh we ran out of things to burn i know
guys i ran out of resources
um so eventually that was when we
realized we had had to go to bed um and
uh so we packed everything up and at
this point it was maybe around minus one
minus two it's starting to get pretty
[ __ ] it was starting to get pretty
really cold uh yeah about it was like
negative degrees
um for you americans that's a negative
from the boiling from the freezing point
of water so i don't know what the
freezing point of water is in fahrenheit
but it was it was below that below 32.
why is it 32. it's 32 fahrenheit is zero
degrees celsius oh okay i didn't know
that i think i did not know that it's 30
something i'm pretty sure right yeah
3.8 is one degree celsius yeah 32 32 is
zero so it's like maybe like 28 yeah
fahrenheit um and this is when we came
to realize how cold it really was going
to be uh without even like a piddly
little fire to uh heat us up and i
remember me and connor uh went into our
tent first so me and connor slept with
nabi in his tent and joey and luke slept
in another tent and everyone else slept
in the third tent
um and i remember connor jumping in
right kind of jumping in and just
realizing
how flimsy and thin his
his sleeping bag was yeah i literally
had gotten a raincoat that had just been
fashioned into
it was like it didn't it didn't have any
padding or anything and i was like this
is what i get yeah ordering the only
available sleeping bag on amazon for the
next day delivery yeah because i was
like it was like 20 bucks yeah because i
remember i think the
warmest coat you have by far is your
drip jacket yeah and this was the one
time in the past month i think i've seen
you without the drip challenges where it
would have been very very useful
the reason i didn't bring it right is
because we were going to be burning a
lot of [ __ ] and i was like i didn't want
to get this this nice jacket that i paid
way too much money for super smoky and i
was probably gonna be messy too it was
messy i dropped condiments everywhere i
was like i'mma just i'm just leaving
yeah yeah i wish i did yeah but yeah so
connor like [ __ ] gets in the sleeping
bag and sleen realizes that this is not
going to be [ __ ] warm enough at all
and he just gets over and he's like gone
gone i give you permission to cuddle me
we are cuddling tonight i'm like we
don't need to cuddle we don't need to
cuddle and then i get into the tent and
i've realized
[ __ ] we're gonna need to cuddle tonight
connor
i i i take off my jackets like as fast
as possible and then and then i try to
like get in the sleeping bag and i zip
myself up i'm [ __ ] freezing and i was
like i saw like like two caterpillars
next to each other like [ __ ] cuddling
with each other and then that still
isn't warm enough so i i kind of
realized pretty soon that i have to
sleep with my jacket on because even
with my jacket off it's not going to be
warm enough um
luckily at this point i think we were
pretty drunk right yeah i must say it
was very funny from the other 10 when
all i could hear was god cuddle me now
get closer to me i was freezing i'll be
the small spoon you be the large spoon
cuddle me now listen i've seen enough
bad girls to know what to do
i i knew i needed to drink my piss
for survival god don't ask but i
fashioned my jeans into a piss filter
i'm already drinking the water you can
go next i've already pissed in a gun i i
was i think i was wearing like maybe six
layers i i had fashioned my my spare
t-shirt and put it around my neck as a
neck warmer
yeah because it was so cold okay what
was the coldest part of your body what
was the part that was hurting
my feet yeah it's the feet for me yeah i
was wearing the family my socks that
didn't help
so one time i was also wearing my family
i was rocking a pair of jeans it was
fine my legs were fine honestly that
wasn't a problem i was wearing a long
sleeve thin shirt with a big thick
jumper yeah and i went to bed using my
coat as the pillow because i didn't have
a pillow yeah woke up at like 2 a.m i
think so i was too cold and i put the
jacket on it didn't really help much um
because by that point i was already too
cold and i feel like it was ice cold i
feel like yeah because i was too cold so
like i wasn't heating up at all so it
didn't it didn't help but my feet were
just too cold yeah yeah so like so like
the tactic that i had in my head right
was uh fall asleep before you really
start feeling the cold yeah i do um and
that's that's why we just like before we
went to the tent we just started [ __ ]
downing beers like nobody's business
we're just like all right can we come
down a little bit yeah let's do it we
[ __ ] we [ __ ] need it to sleep in
this weather uh so we after we down the
beers um and i start calling connor um
it worked like i fell asleep actually
pretty fast yeah me too yeah i've got a
good amount of sleep i think yeah so
good quality sleep i felt rough yeah i i
got like a good three four hours of
sleep because i remember waking up at
around 4am and that's that's when it
really started to hit me the [ __ ]
situation i was in right that was like
the minimum what time was your makeup
did you not sleep at all i no no i slept
i probably slept maybe about two or
three hours and then i woke up at like
four yeah around four-ish the same thing
yeah and then i was just like i i can't
i can't i checked the temperatures like
minus six celsius and i was like [ __ ] it
so see yeah i i know that if you wake up
and you actually start looking at your
phone or stuff you will wake up yeah so
every time i woke up because i woke up
sporadically throughout the night i
would just immediately force myself to
not do anything and go back to sleep
yeah so i got to sleep until around 5 56
i think i remember i i just i got out of
the tin i was like i need to start
walking and that point it was like four
or five degrees minus yeah so i i i got
out at like four am and with like all
the clothes i had on and i was just like
i'm just gonna go for a walk
yeah this is the only way i can i was i
was so much colder walking really yeah
because i had to i had the problem of
what happens when you drink too many
beers you need to pee yeah and so i
really really needed the pee yeah and
the toilet was very far away yeah so i
walked to it i bought a coffee from a
vending machine there to heat my hands
up because i was using i paid 100 i paid
a dollar every time i need to heat my
hands up i was so cold i didn't even
give a [ __ ] i didn't drink the coffee
yeah i just used it as a hand warmer
yeah so it was like saving my life it's
like my lifeline
yeah i had gone through like four of
these one dollar coffee just to keep my
hand warm because i was like
oh my god it was awful and it was it was
dreadful and i i had to go pee and
peeing was painful but in this luckily
the one saving grace of this campsite
was at the hotel at a hotel the the
toilet thank god praise japan had a
bidet and bidets have a heated toilet
seat so i sat on this toilet seat for a
good 15 minutes just going
just knowing that my ass was being
warmed gracefully it was amazing one of
my biggest fears when it goes to camping
right is having to pee
after life after everyone's fallen
asleep right because i have the smallest
[ __ ] bladder in the world out of the
tent and like getting out of the tent
and uh waking everyone everyone up um as
you're going out the tent to pee which
sometimes if i'm drinking i need to pee
two or three times i'm just bringing in
adult diapers yeah luckily they're gonna
warm you up yeah honestly honestly i'll
just bring an adult
it would serve two things would warm up
my legs and my lower half of my body and
uh i wouldn't need to worry about peeing
anymore all right
so i said oh i gotta warm up
i actually remember even before he went
to bed i remember telling these boys
about my irrational fears when it comes
to peeing when i'm camping so
did you always remember this i'm very
stupid
because uh because we were talking about
horror movies before like something to
do with horror movies i can't remember i
was pretty [ __ ] drunk um but any time
i pee in like the wilderness
like every anytime i pee in like the
wilderness like like camping or whatever
um so you go up to like a bush or
something and it's like it's like a bush
that extends as far as the eye can see
yeah anything can be [ __ ] hiding in
that bush i've seen enough horror movies
to know that there's a there could be a
[ __ ] monster or [ __ ] jason on the
other side waiting to chop me up there
could be anything so i'm like i have
this arrangement what are you five years
old
yes joey i'm five years old dexter's
chilling in the bush waiting for you he
could be you know so so like ever since
i was a kid every time i would go up to
pee by myself like i'd hear the boys
just like bantering in the background
and i'd be about like you know 20
20 30 meters away yeah in the dark so
they can't really see me but they know
i'm there so i'm peeing in this bush and
i have this i always have this
irrational fear that something is going
to come out of this bush and like attack
me or grab me or a creature's gonna like
[ __ ] chomp me up or something like
that because that's what happens in
every [ __ ] horror movie it's always
like the guy taking the piss next to the
lake side of the bush that he never
expects he's a bit drunk that's that's
when they die that's when they always
die you need to cut down on the horror
movie
i think sydney's making you watch one
yeah
so every time i go b i'm like eagerly
looking for like any [ __ ] movement
every any like any any any [ __ ] shake
of the bush i'm like ready to like leg
it the other way i don't even care if my
dicks are at this point i'm like i'm
like legging it right
you should be thankful that it was so
cold because if it wasn't that cold i
would have absolutely trolled you no
because
because because it was cold right so
here i am here i am keeping an eagle eye
out of any sign of a possible monster um
that could come out of the bush right um
and then but me being drunk someone like
one of you guys say something funny you
start laughing i look over and i'm just
like huh you know the boys are just
being boys i look back over and i see
something someone's breath just like
just like going towards like a white
cloud yeah like a white cloud i'm like
[ __ ] there's there's a monster hiding in
that bush and then i soon realized
literally half a second in that it's
just my piss steaming
i gave myself
my wrist
my piss gave me like a minute scared
from your penis
my piss gave me like a mini [ __ ]
heart attack
because i thought there was like a
monster hiding in the bush
oh my gosh
so um so yeah that that that already
shows how cold it was even before
uh eve even before we uh started
sleeping so luckily like i i'd held my
piss for as long as i could until like i
woke up yeah and i remember waking up
and i was just can't get back in that
sleeping bag once you wake up no no it's
not possible i gave up no so i remember
waking up and i tried to go back to
sleep um and of course this was this was
the exact moment
that uh connor and abby decide to have a
snoring contest
yes yes you guys still
you guys definitely did it was oh i like
i don't i don't know why they chose this
exact moment right because i remember
waking up why do you think i got my own
tent dude i remember like like you can't
you were like four feet away from me
yeah i i remember waking up right i
remember waking up and it was like dead
silence and i remember
i had about i had like a good ten
minutes of dead silence right and i
remember like i remember like checking
my bladder right to be like do i need to
pee no thank god i don't need to pee
thank god i that like my blood is empty
enough for me to be able to go back to
sleep yeah so i like turn over try and
try and find a nice comfortable position
and then i just i just hear i just hear
kind of next to me going
and then i was just like connor connor
don't don't don't don't you [ __ ] dare
and then he doesn't do anything more and
then nabi just goes
and i'm just like no no please no i like
i get another five seconds of silence
connor turns over
and i'm just like [ __ ] for [ __ ] sake
i'm trying to i'm trying to get the
blood flowing as much
i do remember that moment actually
because that was around the time where i
decided to wake up and all i could hear
was like what sounded like two like
really old motor boats trying to start
off
[Music]
it was just like a feedback loop like
you just kept feeding into each other
and i'm just like i was like are they
going i don't i don't normally snore but
i when i have to sleep on my back that's
when i snore also you guys were drinking
as well right yeah yeah
you snore more when you drink but like
that wasn't the only dilemma i had to go
through because um now at this point i
had sobered up a lot more at least a lot
more that i could definitely definitely
feel the [ __ ] cold right
um so i realized that uh being in a tent
you can warm up your body but the air in
the tent is still cold yeah it is still
cold air um so i was trying to breathe
through my nose and i swear to god every
every breath i took was like freezing
the moisture inside my nose are you
saying you became a mouth breathing no
yeah yeah
so so like while these guys are so vital
tactics
what are these guys are having a [ __ ]
story contest i'm here trying to trying
to successfully breathe through my nose
without it hurting and after about five
minutes i'm just like
what are you i gotta because i'm [ __ ]
demon slayer
i'm going to become the thing i detested
i became a mouth breather but even that
like didn't help like i began i tried
breathing through my mouth but it was
still too [ __ ] cold
so i had to like take my i had to take
my jacket off right and try to fashion
this kind of pillow scarf kind of thing
where
my face was being covered right so that
like i had enough air so like so like it
was it was like playing or something
yeah yeah yeah kind of so i i tried to i
tried to masquerade this [ __ ] mask on
me where i had enough i had enough air
um to breathe but it was also insulating
the cold air yeah um that didn't work
because then um if anyone's tried to
sleep with like the blanket over your
head you soon realize that uh you can't
[ __ ] breathe yeah you can't breathe
you're very stuffy yeah you're gonna get
very stuffy you're probably gonna die of
like carbon dioxide poisoning yeah um so
basically i had to make the choice of
trying to sleep um suffocating myself
or freezing my lungs and uh neither
neither choice sounded like a good
choice to me so here i am for 30 minutes
like i would i would put the cover over
my head try to breathe through it for a
good like 30 minutes doesn't work take
it off find another position so that
you're like one step away from like just
breathing your own farts yeah i mean
that might have honestly been the best
one honestly i i that if i would have
taken any [ __ ] solution that worked
um but like eventually me me trying to
go to sleep connor eventually wakes up
and he goes out the tent
um and so i try sleeping for another
another like half an hour to 45 minutes
before i just give up and just try going
out and at that point everyone's already
out yeah um so i didn't know what these
guys were doing i thought i thought
connor had like gone for a walk or
something
um i thought you know i thought maybe
they'd gone back to another ten i had no
idea what they're doing because i
remember them talking outside but when i
went outside nobody was there
so
so i i remember um i remembered like
trying to find where everyone was and
then for some reason i just i felt the
car or i heard the car engine like
purring right yeah i'm just like why is
the car on what's going on here and keep
in mind i had contacts on uh before i
slept so i had taken them off so i
couldn't see [ __ ] so i was like trying
to feel my way through everything was
blurry for me um so i go towards the car
and i see connor just [ __ ] sleeping
on the driver's seat
these [ __ ]
had
had gone into the car brain had gone
into the car turned the engine on
and just slept in the [ __ ] car
[ __ ] the camping trip
they had gone back to civilization right
listen i in my mind i'm like listen i've
slept it's 6 a.m it's technically
morning i've awoken now i want to get
warm
i'm going to the [ __ ] car
because at that point i was like what do
we actually do i don't know what to do
i can't sit on the toilet for hours like
like we're not gonna we're not gonna
leave for a few more hours yeah and i
was like there's nowhere i can go to get
warm all right i no one can accuse me of
not camping i slept in the tent until
six a.m i'm now going in the car to heat
up so i i i joined him uh obviously yeah
turn the engine on for a bit and then it
got hot enough and then the sound was
starting to come out so we just turned
it off yeah and then we're just chilled
in the car i slept like four hours i
mean i'm giving them [ __ ] but the only
reason i'm giving them [ __ ] was because
i saw kind of sleeping in the car i'm
just like
you [ __ ] genius big brain mode i like
exactly i excitedly opened the car door
being like you [ __ ] geniuses and then
i quickly see that all the [ __ ] seats
are taken
so originally i was like come on joe
let's go in the car i'm gonna go in the
car and i don't want i didn't want all
this wasted electricity that i'm using
because it's a massive waste of
electricity yeah but the time i was like
i'm gonna die i'm just gonna i'm gonna
get in the car it's minus four [ __ ] this
uh these people were taking photos of
fuji yeah they were dying for their
craft and i salute them but not me i had
nothing to gain from that yeah so i was
i'm getting the car joey come on in and
then and then slowly everyone started
trying to get in the car
because they were also freezing and then
i basically turned into like a sauna
where like people were coming in and out
like just trying to warm up yeah because
like i opened the car door and every
[ __ ] seat was taken and it like it
wasn't filmed because like i'm glad it
wasn't filmed because it would have
would have quickly turned into like the
salty saltiest moment of trash
because i was like
[ __ ] these guys
[ __ ] these guys [ __ ] them and i went for
a walk trying to figure out how i'm
going to warm myself up it was great
like because the car was slightly on a
hill as well so when i
uh reclined the chair yeah it was
literally like a flat bed yeah yeah yeah
and this one on the aircon which is
blasting yeah it doesn't really do
anything for the first like 10 minutes
because the car wasn't moving yeah so
just like what we're doing yeah so i'm
i'm still like tired as [ __ ] i start
walking around i try taking some nice
photos of fuji but at this point i'm
like [ __ ] dying i couldn't i'm sorry
[ __ ] you could have you could have got
in you know
there was
i found a way to warm myself up um
so this is this is like me using like
100 of my brain right because i'm an
engineer and what do engineers do we
problem solve right
i did that too
yeah you did i can't believe you're not
problem solving unfortunately i couldn't
go for the same solution because uh nabi
was like fast asleep so i couldn't be
like nabi give me the car get the [ __ ]
out get the [ __ ] out let's go into the
car
yeah
so um
so i walk over uh to take the piss you
know to take a piss in the toilet and i
see the vending machine and then
then like the [ __ ] the [ __ ] bulb
just like lights above my head i'm just
like guys
i've figured this out so i go back to my
tent i get my wallet right
i get my wallets and i just i just start
putting coins in i start buying coffee
because connor how many did you buy i
bought
that sounds more inefficient than using
the car
probably it probably is but i i that
that was the only solution i could come
up with right now why did you not just
jump in the other car we had two cars
it's canned coffees by the way not yeah
so so to explain we had a vending
machine there and japanese vending
machines have this option where some of
the drinks are warmed right and that was
the only source of heat i could find in
like a five mile radius at this point
right so so here i am like
spending like a hundred yen for like a
coffee which to me i just like i just
like heat packs right yeah i start
packing them into my coat right
at this point i like i i like actually
like start rationing them so i start
so
i take about six coffees [ __ ] rush
back to the tent go back into my
sleeping bag i like throw throw two cans
at my feet because that's where my feet
my foot were the coldest and the rest i
started like packing in my winter jacket
so i pack some some some in my like
bottom pockets some in like my side my
sleeve pockets some of my side pockets
have the best [ __ ] sleep of my life
man
it worked it actually [ __ ] works i
got like i got like some proper air
circulation in this [ __ ] sleeping bag
man
i felt so rough the next day
i slept like 10 hours as well i just
felt awful yeah yeah i think because
there's something about eating like just
meat as well that just makes me feel
awful
yeah i get that
and a lot of beers we didn't have the
best diet the night before so yeah when
i just meet like only me i feel like my
body feels like beaten up like i need
some like something else to help stomach
the blow
yeah
so yeah more of the story is um you know
you're more prepared
don't underestimate the winter yeah i
thought it would be fine who gives a
[ __ ] about what bear grylls says when
you could just get warm coffee that's
the secret that's the secret just get in
the car why do beer girls not go to the
nearest vending machine all you need is
a company just go to a vending machine
let's go to the vending machine pack
yourself some warm [ __ ] coffee and
just use that [ __ ] warm yourself up i
don't know why russians are complaining
like i've seen siberian winters
you just need a vending machine
their car engines freeze
don't they leave the cars on sometimes
because the it freezes otherwise did you
also watch that video of the dude who
went to siberia was it really there was
that video that went viral it was on my
recommended recently it's got like 30
million views in like six months or
something of this dude who went to uh
yakutst in siberia which is like the
coldest part of the world it's like
minus 71 degrees or something it's
colder than untold it's cold now
yeah gotta fact-check that actually yeah
yeah but uh it's it's called yakutst
y-a-k-u-t-s-k
i think something like that where's the
coolest place on earth but it's uh it's
in siberia uh and uh yeah this dude like
does this like amazing mini documentary
of him there and he's like yeah so uh
here i've got some boiling water at 100
degrees uh and i'm gonna throw it out
into the air and it'll instantly freeze
and he just throws it and i've seen that
turns into snow yeah because it's like
minus 50 degrees and it's like uh so in
normal circumstances uh if it's anywhere
below zero degrees then school is
cancelled but here in jacques as long as
it doesn't hit -50 yeah kids are going
to school i was like what the [ __ ]
yeah it's insane i remember seeing
videos like that um
not just in siberia but i think like
recently somewhere in america had like a
cold front where it was like texas was
it texas yeah texas yeah where the same
way i saw videos of people doing the
same thing where they would throw out
throughout the water uh don't don't
quote me on this because i'm not sure if
it was texas but it was texas it was
terrible are you sure they're cold front
yeah
all the electrical grid broke yeah this
guy discover with senate 32 million
views six months ago oh wow yeah minus
71 degrees celsius minus 96 fahrenheit
yeah it's not the coldest place but it's
probably it's one
yeah i'm pretty sure that like
antarctica is like yeah oh yeah i mean
like yeah like center of the arctic
circle
but no one's living there yeah yeah so i
i would see videos of people you know
throwing boiling water out and you'd see
it freeze and steam instantly
um but my favorite thing was
people who didn't realize that uh
boiling water is still boiling water
yeah and if you chuck it on yourself
even if it's like negative like negative
20 degrees weather outside there's still
going to be some boiling water you're
still going to burn yourself yeah you're
still going to [ __ ]
chucking it on themselves huh they were
chucking it they were chugging it in the
air yeah and the water oh you know
because you know how gravity works it
would fall down on them
so yeah the more you know boiling water
is still boiling cold things are cold
and uh camping in negative four degrees
weather of negative i'm sure there's
going to be like some like pro camping
people watching this just cringing to
death hearing all the fails but that's
can be [ __ ] everything up yeah it's
still fine it's part of the fun yeah
i'm sure there's gonna be people some
people watching me like what negative
six negative five that's that's not cool
yeah but that's how it always is you can
be like oh you you woke up at 4am bro i
wake up at 1am every day and i i inject
meth into my eyes it's like you don't
know you don't know what waking up weak
morning routine it's like shut the [ __ ]
up like just let people complain about
what is relative to them for a moment
please yeah look all i'm saying is
you're like yuri camp lied to me it made
it it it portrayed like they went
camping in the winter and they didn't
need to go to the [ __ ] car to warm
themselves up they were kind of [ __ ]
comfy in a little coach i don't know i
want to see that european like where's
the euro cap episode where they become
mouth breathers oh that's that if they
don't become mouth breathers then i
don't think it's accurate honestly do
they have clearly defined nose
okay no they don't they don't there
might be another three things they
probably aren't they're probably math
previously
i need to take a fist this episode is
sponsored by harry's harry's is an
award-winning razor brand that makes a
full range of grooming essentials and
they were founded on the belief that you
shouldn't have to choose between an
incredible shave and a fair price you
guys know already i use harry's i pretty
much only shave with harry's i know that
sounds like an ad but it's real when i
went back to the uk they actually sold
harry's in the uk and
i put like five boxes of the 12-pack
raises in my suitcase oh genuinely right
it's the cleanest share i'm telling you
these races are clean very good and they
last a while and what a perfect time
because it's that time of the year again
time for a fresh start and new
resolutions whether you're trying to
manage your finances better or just
trying to look your best going into the
new years harry's can help with that and
to start the new year with some savings
new customers can redeem a harry's trial
set for just three smackaroos harry
delivers a close comfortable shave at a
fair price as low as two dollars per
blade and guys harry's is giving their
best offer to our listeners no new
harry's customers can redeem a starter
set you get a five blade razor a
weighted handle foaming shave gel an
alloy and a travel cover to protect your
blades when you're on the go that's
thirteen dollars value for just three
dollars there's truly never been a
better time to try harry's go to harry's
dot com slash trash taste to try harry's
today back to the episode do you guys
have any irrational fears
because i don't know if i'm like the
only one who has like
how irrational i don't know
i don't know what what what's your
biggest fear joey what is your biggest
fear my biggest fear what is your
biggest irrational fear great beard okay
then we'll actually go sorry decide to
bring up the campaign we'll go back to
the restaurant we'll go back to that oh
yeah that that the beer definitely
helped staying warm i got admitted
yeah yeah my face was never cold oh yeah
but didn't like your snot like freeze
yeah so so here because i had a cold it
was so cold yeah uh my snot like like
obviously you must have dribbled while
sleeping it like froze on the like arch
of my underneath my nose and it was
awful because i was like what is this
and i flicked it and then just peeled
off all my skin and i was like wow
ow but yeah the beard otherwise is great
yeah yeah but i think this is the
longest i'll let it go it's getting long
does it get any longer than that it can
do oh really i think it will keep going
longer and longer oh damn i kind of want
to see you with like the lumber yeah
part of me wants to try it but i'm like
maybe i should just save that for when
i'm bald
well no you got to test it out now
before you go yeah
see if it works all right but i'm not
going to lie i i don't know if there's
there's probably a lot of bearded people
watching this it kind of is getting like
somewhat itchier than than usual yeah
do you get this do you get this bearded
people i don't know
they probably know solutions that are
like
how you maintain a beard perfectly which
i don't know i i sometimes like one time
i grew it out to as long as it could and
it's like i don't think you'll ever get
as long as yours but like it i remember
one time i'm not the baby stages yeah
i'm still growing yeah but like i think
that length that you have is probably
the longest it can go for me oh really
yeah because my asian side forbids it i
will say that like doing this feels
really nice like just like yeah yeah
have you gone to the point though where
you're like kind of turning in your bed
and your beard brushes up against the
the pillow and it starts to get a bit
issue sometimes yeah well the worst
thing is because we have to wear masks
like yeah oh yeah when it's getting old
with the mask
shock it's the light i'm just like
because the it's like i'm breathing in
like my own beard like jungle i can feel
it it's ticklish as well yeah it's like
wet yeah it's awful how long are you
going to grow it i'm probably going to
shave it tonight not all off i'm just
going to cut it sorry yeah
because i've got a video shoot tomorrow
yeah i'm going to be sad to stop letting
it grow but maybe maybe i'll try it
again you should you should try it you
should try it i'll do it again how come
you wanted to grow out a bit longer then
i just wanted to see if it looked better
thicker i think it does look a little
better thicker
than normal then i just definitely adds
on the age yeah everyone i look older i
look more angry it doesn't look older
with a beard though it's true that's
what i'm saying all right i could
probably lick my age if i grew a beard
yeah
probably i i could see gone in 10 years
with a goatee i don't know why i want to
see that gone with a goatee i could see
it i think i've ever seen you with like
have you ever like grown out your like
beard to like see the where the absolute
limit is before it stops growing or no
because i don't like how i look with a
beard a lot of the times i there's like
this goatee gone
there's like this perfect sweet spot and
then it just kind of looks like pubes um
like it goes from like nine o'clock
shadow to like wow you uh really should
trim that [ __ ] bush mate yeah yeah
yeah you know and so so i i always like
trim it when it gets to that point
um so i i don't know if i'm ever gonna
go out the beard because yes because
cindy's like yeah it's a good idea it's
a good idea then i reached the pube
stage just like maybe shrimp because
because everything's in between phases
that look like yeah
after the pubes
maybe maybe i will wonder goatee gone
everyone has the pube stage you have to
go beyond the bro he wears
exactly go t gon do it maybe maybe one
day maybe do it maybe when i reach like
my mid-life crisis and like you know you
know how like you know you know i'm
gonna be the first one there you know
i'm like and when i could do a goatee i
could just shave it all off and be like
hello fellow go-to
i did a go team once when i was shaving
and immediately i was like oh god i look
i i i look like i touched children like
it was it was like what the [ __ ] it was
actually
like i immediately i was immediately
like nope i'm not having this on my face
any longer calling out anyone with a
goat
as opposed to like
it just doesn't work for me like i i
realized i have one of those faces that
just like it's either a beard or nothing
like
like beard and stuff like that with like
the really thin beard i don't like that
that doesn't work for me mustache
doesn't work for me goatee doesn't work
for me it's either this or nothing
and i just have one of those faces i
realized you just have to try it out
right i wish mustaches were more in i
like i like i wish i could rock a
monster must actually look kind of sick
i wish i had the face
just looks like you're about to invent
something yeah
you look like you're about to pioneer
something yeah it depends on what kind
of mustache you have right see like you
could work a mustache but i don't think
i don't get like you know that thing
that people have when you don't grow
that much hair in the middle
you need you need it to grow more there
i don't think you would suit him i don't
think so i don't think so no i also
think you'd look like you touched
children
come on you're giving people with a
mustache a bad rap here boys no no no no
no no no people some people can rock it
so hard and i'm so jealous of people who
can do that like with the same like if
you had a mustache and those like
[ __ ] massive glasses you know you
know you know what i mean like those
[ __ ] massive glasses you would
definitely the johnson look like you're
calling out some of our viewers they're
probably gone no but i'm sure they don't
look that bad
just saying it's just my face my face is
just like this like for some people it
just works and there's no explanation
for it like here's a still image mudan
i've seen dudes with like just mustaches
just goatees just bootstraps where it's
like [ __ ] you could put some put some
put some glasses on him as well put some
big gloves put some glasses and then uh
yeah and then you'll see it just doesn't
work for some people i don't know
maybe it works maybe it's just like my
imagination
if it looks amazing you you have to i
think i'd look like a a 90s porn star
is that a good thing or a bad thing it's
a great thing
you know the thousands of porn stars the
johnny sins zero second yeah yeah
nineties is mustaches you know all that
that's like 70s
70s porn stars had like the thick thick
mustache that was a look that was a look
bring it back on
maybe i will
[Music]
how much commitment does it take i don't
know how long this has taken this has
taken a while yeah my max i think is
like maybe a month and a half two months
and then and then it hits a point where
it just won't grow any longer ah that's
a long [ __ ] time yeah
it takes a long time to grow it takes a
long time
that i don't have
and it looks scruffy in the middle part
you know when it's a full beard and i
can trim it properly yeah it looks good
when when i reach my mid-life prices
that's when i'll grow a beard you know
you're saying are you saying i reach for
mid-life sorry have i reached my midlife
crisis i mean maybe you have not i
wouldn't i haven't got my health check
doing something crazy with your facial
hair is like the like the main
equivalent of you know when girls want a
big change in their life and they just
like [ __ ] cut their hair off or
something
[Music]
that's it's like the main equivalent
like i broke up i cut my hair why is it
gone why we should we kill it
like like you know when we need to
change the sigma
statement stigma stigma
because you need to change the signal if
you grow a beard at any point in your
life you're a sigma you deserve it go
you go bro get it get a beard what if
you can't grow a beard though that sucks
to be you wrong
some people just get all the sigma but
that doesn't mean you're having a
midlife crisis if you grow a beard can't
[ __ ] you
[Music]
you can grow facial hair if you want to
king go ahead
in like my early twenties yeah middle of
course yeah
that is true
i believe yeah but anyway going back to
rational figures
so
like i i remember like think i was like
have we set off ears on a podcast before
like our main fears oh no no we did an
episode where we talked about our fears
right we talked about stuff like that
no we we talked about was like scared
off huh was i scared of like tight
spaces
i remember we were talking oh yeah
we talked about like crawling into tight
spaces yeah yeah because you were
talking about the cave story yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah cause like i remember
like i i just realized this as i was
taking another piss where most of my
rational fears come from um and yeah it
is from horror movies right yeah and
it's specifically from horror movies
that i would watch as a kid and that's i
think that's why like i [ __ ] detest
horror movies because i remember
like most of the horror movies i've
watched in my life are between the age
of like
five to ten years old right and the
reason for this is like every time i go
to my cousin's house
he'd put on a horror movie right how'd
it start is i'd go around to my cousin's
house and be like oh can we go to dragon
ball z can we watch dragon ball z and
every night and so like they put on
dragon ball z and i'd be [ __ ] into it
right and then all the parents would go
off and do their own thing and you know
they would they would they would ask
like the older cousins to take care of
the kids as soon as as soon as the
adults left they were like
yo you want to see a horror movie
you want to see someone get butchered
and i'm like no that scares me it gives
you nightmares
huh how old are you between like five
and ten years old [ __ ] yeah
so a little too young yeah so i remember
i think i was like seven or something
and i will i would like what okay so i'm
gonna say the irrational fear okay
so
every time i approach my car
and it's just like in a in a car park
could be empty could be full right um
but i'm by myself and it's dark first
thing i have to do check the back seat
make sure no one's in it
second thing i have to do i have to like
go under and check that there's nobody
hiding underneath my car you show that
every time i i like
like nine percent of the time i do it
because i don't feel safe unless i do it
right what's gonna be under your car
okay here's here's the monster here no
no here's the reason why okay so
when i was about i can't remember it's
like between five and seven i think i
was like seven years old uh i go to my
cousin's house and of course it's like
god it's a horror movie time again i'm
like no please no it's like no it's
we're putting in the horror movie this
time it's [ __ ] urban legends right um
it's it's uh like i don't know if it's
good i was it [ __ ] scared the [ __ ]
out of me as a kid i'll tell you that
and i've never watched it since
um but uh you might get ptsd if you're
watching now honestly it'll overcome
your fear or maybe maybe it's it's like
a slasher horror movie so it was like it
was like 90s so that's when like slasher
horror movies were in the screamier yeah
the screen mirror so like that's that's
kind of the horror movie era that i grew
up with and that's the kind of horror
movies that traumatized me yeah um and i
remember
um it was this guy i can't remember the
exact movie the exact things that
happened but i remember it was surprise
surprise about urban legends so you
you'd have these urban legends that were
spread out and sometimes these urban
legends would come true i can't remember
what the exact urban legends were um but
i remember this one scene
um it was it was a guy who was basically
dressed up as death and he had a scythe
right
and so i think part of the urban legend
was
that there would be this guy in the back
of your car while you're driving
and this actually happened in the movie
there was there was this person driving
the car and how he died was someone
emerged from the back yeah with a
[ __ ] scythe and just [ __ ] chopped
him up to death right right and of
course as a kid that [ __ ] terrified
me because i remember thinking
if if i ever get if i ever grow up and
get my driver's license at any point in
the dark someone could come up from the
back seat and [ __ ] stab me in the
neck or [ __ ] slice my neck open i
kind of get it and so and so and so and
so
like that is just ingrained into my
[ __ ] mind but the second the second
death in that movie or maybe it might be
the third or the fourth i can't remember
so this so this rumor gets spread around
right
that uh there's there's a guy in the
backseat that you can you know there's a
serial killer and this is how this
person died
and so of course the fourth guy he
thinks he's better than this he goes
towards his car he's a bit scared but
what does he do he checks the back seat
of course he's like
i beat the system it's so dumb
out of nowhere the guy is hiding
underneath the car and slices his ankles
right
and then he starts [ __ ] crawling away
and like i i remember this scene to this
day and that's why if i ever approach a
car i'm beating the system first thing
i'm doing i'm checking underneath the
car second thing i'm doing i'm checking
i'm checking the back seat right there
there there's no
and like but then what if death's like
big
twist passengers look look look if
there's a sequel if there's like urban
legends too where there's like there's
like someone adds on to this system i'm
[ __ ] right but until then i'm checking
underneath every car i go to and every
back seat if i'm by myself because i'm
not getting my ankles sliced off i'll
tell you that much how did this man
that's a nitpick but yeah how do they
use a scythe in a car what was this like
i don't know suv
yeah this must have been a big sight
you can't swing it in a car
scythes are not short tools maybe a
sickle circle might have worked i like
how that's your first question and not
how did you get into the car yeah
yeah the first thing i was thinking when
he said this how did this man swing a
scythe in a car i can barely swing my
arms in a car
that's a good question i should have
asked that as a kid apart maybe if he
you know he kind of like put it forward
and then brought it backwards but then
how would you slice it underneath i feel
like if you send you know there's a lot
of ways this could go wrong you're being
a little too like realistic here right
we first have to question why is death
in my car
you know i feel like as an adult you can
pick apart the plot holes in a lot of
horror movies and that's they stopped
being scary
he's bleeding he's bleeding what the
[ __ ] i get i get that like back seat
like [ __ ] because like there's a lot
of like japanese horror films as well
that's like that's like a very cliche
the other one that scares me is uh
and i hated this because my new place
that i currently have has this but in
the bathroom your mirror has a medicine
cabinet
okay
it's the thing like you're brushing your
teeth and then you know
the medicine cabinet's slightly open and
then you close the medicine cabinet and
then the monster is standing behind you
right it's like
every now and then i have that thing
where like if i'm like in the dark and
the medicine cabinet is open before i
close it i just
look behind me
like do you like a single breath before
you close you're just like okay
yeah yeah yeah i'm kind of like i see it
open i'm like
okay i'm good
we're good guys we get it let's go
i get that every now and then
i don't have like any rituals like that
to like stop me from being scared of
something like that
i don't know i just i feel like
i i think to this day there's some part
about me where it's like i'm still
scared of the dark yeah right because
for what for what [ __ ] reason right
like it's not because it's like i'm
afraid of the guy behind me you know as
i'm at the medicine cabinet or whatever
but it's like you know in the back of
your head in the back of your [ __ ] up
imagination somewhere you're like yeah
this is a possibility it's like when
you're i don't know when you're sleeping
and you're like did i leave my door open
yeah you know you didn't but now you're
gonna go check yeah yeah cause you're
like i thought i did but i definitely
didn't i'm gonna but i have to
write it's kind of like that where you
like you make yourself think something
is there so now you have to check
exactly otherwise you can't stop
thinking about it i think i had stuff
like that with like yeah there's there
could be a monster on the other side of
the bed if i turn around
but i won't know unless i turn around i
guess i won't turn around
i have had thoughts like that
but i never actually like even wanted it
to practice even when i think like oh i
could just like die if there was like a
guy standing in my whole way with a
knife i don't actually like think that
he's gonna be there but i check
but like i know you check just in case
there's no way in hell someone's there
yeah but you just have to confirm it
because i i i also get that every now
and again where it's like the most
irrational thoughts
um where you know
sometimes there's you know you close the
door and you're like
maybe there's a guy on the other side
maybe maybe there's someone in my house
right now yeah i i don't know and
especially like especially in the night
time and you like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
hear something in the middle of the
night
in like your living room and you're like
i know there's nothing in my house
but what if what was that it was a what
if i like i'm pretty sure there's no
ghosts in my house i don't you know
i confide in my belief of ghost that
this place isn't [ __ ] haunted or
whatever even if you know there might be
some haunted places in the world i'm
pretty sure this place is not unhaunted
but then what the [ __ ] was that noise
like it could be the wind definitely not
the wind
definitely the wind definitely not the
wind
you start second-guessing yourself you
know exactly and i feel that like
especially recently with like some
horror games i play like i feel that
just like resurfaced yeah it's it's not
until you recently consume content like
that that you start to realize oh yeah i
think i'm still afraid of this [ __ ] like
yeah i remember after i played pt for
the first time yeah like that made me so
late i was like hallways lights on
everywhere i go
like i'm not i'm not turning this [ __ ]
off [ __ ] that
it's like so it's like it's so
irrational it's like of course the
[ __ ] she's not going to be standing
there at the end of the war irrational
fear that someone who's close to you is
like not okay and then you just text him
like are you okay
i get that i get it yeah yeah you're
like yeah i had this weird dream just
checking in that you're all right you
haven't texted me in a while
we good you're good
[Music]
sometimes i'm just like sometimes you go
to like a night out or like you hang out
with someone and you're just like
they didn't they said like 10 words less
than what they usually said
maybe there's something going on they
were blinking a lot more than usual
they were
yeah like i think part of the reason why
i have so many lights on my house is
because it's because of irrational fears
like this like my mom
would [ __ ] bollock me as a kid
because every time i but my mom and dad
would go out they'd come home to a house
full of lights
and they're all like god stop wasting
electricity
and for the longest time i think they
just thought i would forget to turn off
the lights and i never just told them no
i'm just actually scared
what if there's like darkness and what
if there's something hiding in that
darkness mom you don't know i mean i'm
in this house by them by myself
they died in the dark exactly you never
know exactly what if squid game just
happens in your room while you're
sleeping you have to start defending
yourself surprise squid game
so the trash tastes camping it's like
when the lights went off
when the fire went out everyone was like
get ready
i did come to the realization of course
not the realization but
like the appreciation of just
lights
oh my god especially camping especially
camping right you really do appreciate
lights and fire the appreciation of
lights oh my gosh
jesus christ you know heat it's pretty
good
being warm is uh a vital part light's
pretty underrated
there's just just some things you just
like you know clothes is actually pretty
useful honestly they're pretty hard
yeah no [ __ ] they are khan look i've i'm
just saying okay i've never appreciated
a hot shower more than after we came
back from that camping trip
i could just like turn on the hot water
and immediately just warm myself up yeah
i'm just like damn man this this this
shower is hitting different
it is hitting different man that was the
best shower and sleep i had when we came
back it was so good yeah i actually
think that fixed my sleeping schedule
because i've been getting up at like a
reasonable time yeah since i got back
from that uh ever since i did i knocked
out like 9 p.m dude yeah
so i was like
so yeah anything else you guys want to
bring up or anything nope just want to
let you know that
no clickbait in this episode we did
actually almost died twice three times
if you include you know the the surprise
attack from the bush
[Music]
was this close to death i'm surprised
jason almost died from from getting
scared by his own piss stream i'm just
saying i love you cuz but uh [ __ ] you at
the same time for literally like you're
an [ __ ] cousin
that's so nice i love my cars
was he a teenager oh he's a teenager uh
he's seven years older than me so yeah
he's the closest thing i have to an
older brother and that's thinking about
that's a very older brother thing that
is a very old i love you guys you you
are like an older you are like an older
brother to me but also
[ __ ] you for showing me that all those
[ __ ] horror movies as a kid
oh it's so terrifying i remember one
thing for some reason that sticks out my
mind my old brother teaching me he's
like yeah you know what socks are for
right and i was like no what a socks for
he's like to clean up the the messes
that you spill on the floor and i'm like
oh what
that makes a lot of sense like like when
you when you're holding a cup of tea and
you spill it on the floor it's like step
one
just use yourself and i was like i was
like
i don't know if that's the dumbest thing
ever or if an actual life hack and i was
like you know what that's kind of big
break it's kind of a big break if it's
not like a big spill obviously if it's
big don't just stop putting yourself
that's an awful piece no it's not if
it's a little bit little spill if you
have some thick socks
there is nothing worse than wet socks
what for like a brief moment your body
how much water how much water are we
talking about like a tiny bit of
spillage on a cup of tea or something
and then you and then you rub it on the
carpet to like warm it up and dry it off
if it's if it's a spill that you can
actually feel on your like on your foot
on the surface i do for a brief moment
i still do it to this day but but hey
the floor is clean it's like it's like
kicking ice under the fridge
what do you mean when you spill ice you
kick it under the fridge that's a nice
thing
i mean i don't do it anymore but
yeah you don't you don't put it in the
sink and if you drop the ice while
you're like popping it yeah
okay well it depends on how much ice
comes out two or three cubes just kind
of
get it
just kick it under
just damage the floor you know did you
rather teach you that as well no i did
that
that's what you're gonna that's what
you're gonna teach your kid when uh when
when you get i hope my kid never watches
trash tapes this is on five minute life
hack kick the ice this is a trash taste
life this is like a reverse life hacks
[ __ ] you shouldn't do
you think i'm going to ruin family mart
socks like that exactly come on you're
going to put them in the wash after no
that's that's that's because of white
black just i only have black socks well
i mean that's your life right yeah just
buy black socks don't think
does that mean you don't burn family
mart socks no i don't
i'm fine with not doing that i'm happy
with my socks i like having black socks
i don't have to think but if family mod
brought out a black sock variant
okay then the family mod i hope you're
listening i mean you do need some black
socks yeah joey joey looking at you joey
what i have black socks no you just
never went
i swear to god every picture that's been
taken within like the past month i see
those [ __ ] family mother socks poking
out i'm out of the outfit
i have about nine pairs of family my
socks and i just cycle through it every
week
they're poor supplier of socks is like
just going back to like a random thing
like okay i gotta ask you all right so
you hear something in the living room
right yeah maybe you're half asleep how
does aki handle that she's like go to
the living room she asked you to check
it yeah she's like uh sweetie can you go
check it i'm like woman
why am i the one to go
you're the one that's curious you go
yeah yeah yeah i i hate it right because
i'm not scared until they ask me to
check and i fell i swear like their fear
gets like transferred over to me
you know before that i was just like oh
i guess uh something knocked over in the
middle of the other guess is just a
piece of wind and then i hear something
come on come on i hear something in the
i guess i'm in the living room come on
go check it go on i'm like sydney it's
probably nothing i need you to go check
it now yeah i'm like [ __ ] me okay
now that i'm going to check now i'm like
and then resident evil music starts
playing in my head i was like oh my god
there's a zombie in the living room and
then like i have i have to if i'm going
to check the living room even if i know
it's nothing i have to find a possible
weapon just in case just just in case
just in case you know and i i have to
like find something that i can smack a
possible animal or a person with yeah
did your houses have chimneys no you
ever slept in a house with a chimney
no they make a lot of noise do they yeah
like unsettling noises
because oh no i i i have i have had i
had i did live in house with the jimmy
as a kid and uh
uh it was blocked up but it still made
like the oh when it's open [ __ ] the
noises that those make are like [ __ ]
terrifying yeah like
wolf howling all the time
literally like the stereotypical ghost
noise yeah
yeah it could be pretty scary what if
it's not the wind what if it's just a
bunch of ghosts
[Music]
it's cold
it's from all the ghosts from all the
gantts that got killed in bushes
hey man i need the statistics of how
many people have been killed while
pissing next to a bush
i just need to put my mind at me i'm
gonna bet that most of the deaths are
from electric fences and then peeing on
them yeah probably something like that
or or an animal coming out or something
you know like a bear
[Music]
but how do i distinguish between an
animal ruffling the bushes and just the
wind because like all
like because the wind is very like it's
very different it's right it's like
yeah but like an animal's like
you will hear like and you'll see it
violently moving yeah you'll see it even
though you're there you'll see it like
on the top i don't know man jurassic
park has told me difference jurassic
park game's [ __ ] come on it's a great
movie but it's not going to give you any
survival tips
what you're going to you're going to go
out into the bush and think oh [ __ ] what
is the velociraptor
england man we have nothing be scared of
in england
japanese policemen randomly stopping you
in the middle of the field asking you to
be checked as opposed to it i have to
wrestle if you're a japanese policeman
coming out of the boys
stopping you from peeing in a bush when
you do from an animal or something
killing you i'd rather get arrested than
uh violently murdered by an animal man
well that's all up that's all i'm saying
i want to be caught with your dick down
and a flashlight standing on you no that
is not what you want
that is true and uh that's been our
irrational fears on trash chase today
you know who hasn't died from peeing in
the bush our patrons yes look at all
these i have them whatever i don't know
look at all these guys
look at all these people that haven't
almost died maybe you have i don't know
i don't know maybe something maybe
you've escaped death or maybe you've
from the backseat of the club maybe
tell us your near-death experiences in
the comments down below also tell us
tell us your irrational fears do you
check the back seat of the car before
going in do you check underneath the
gun's trying to find something please
please i can't be the only one okay i
can't be the only one who has a weird
ritual in my life just because of some
[ __ ] movie i saw as a kid that i
can't forget okay i was looking for the
17 red posts for that hey if you like to
smooth the show then make sure to go to
the patreon patreon.com also follow us
on twitter send us your means on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify and get some
trash taste if you haven't read oh yeah
get the trash
look at this
look at that look at that we have
t-shirts we have hoodies is it gonna be
available in this uh yeah it comes out
to pre-order yeah yeah if we were
re-ordering grab something and grab some
right now link's in the description
check it out but uh yeah yeah bye games
bye
[Music]
foreign